Hey everybody, so we're coming off the heels of our first duo episode in a long time. We've had a lot of really amazing interviews and we took a little break to do a show with just the two of us, but we have an absolutely phenomenal guest on and I wanted to get Kevin on the show and get this episode out to folks because it's something that is so important. Ultimately, when we build software, most of us, we're building it for other people. I mean, even if you're making a compiler, you have an audience in mind.
大家好，我们刚刚结束了很久以来的第一次双人播客。我们之前做了很多非常棒的采访，所以这次休息了一下，只由我们两个人来做一期节目。不过，我们今天请到了一位非常出色的嘉宾，我一直想请凯文（Kevin）来节目，并把这期内容分享给大家，因为它非常重要。归根结底，当我们开发软件时，我们大多数人都是在为他人开发。我的意思是，即使你在编写编译器，你心中也会有一个目标用户群体。
And so how do we sort of reach that audience? How do we learn more about what we want to build? Marketing and digital marketing is a huge part of that whole experience. And we have Kevin Rutia on who is the founder of Voi Media, who's going to teach us all about, you know, marketing and digital marketing and the ins and outs of it. So thanks for being on the show, Kevin. Hey, guys, thanks for having me. Super excited to be here. Cool. So we kind of asked everyone, or at least in the past year, how they're holding up with COVID
那么，我们该如何触达这些用户呢？我们该如何更多地了解我们想要构建的东西？市场营销和数字营销是整个体验中非常重要的一部分。我们请到了 Voi Media 的创始人凯文·鲁蒂亚（Kevin Rutia），他将教我们关于市场营销和数字营销的一切，以及其中的门道。所以，感谢你来到节目，凯文。嘿，伙计们，谢谢邀请。很高兴能来到这里。太棒了。我们之前问过每个人，或者至少在过去的一年里，问过他们是如何应对新冠疫情的，
and how their sort of job has changed with the lockdown and everything. Yeah. So funny enough, yesterday was our company's one year anniversary of working from home. So it's been one year. Yeah. It's been one year since. It's funny because I was like, so I have a cleaning company too here in New York City. And we're like, oh, whoa, crazy. It's been a year. And then I was like, oh yeah, it's been a year for my other company too. Because we have like a shared office in New York City. And we're like, oh, whoa, crazy. It's been a year. And then I was like, oh yeah, it's been a year for my other company too. Because we have like a shared office in New York City that we do for my cleaning company and then the marketing company, Waymedia, right? But yeah, it's been a year and it's kind of crazy because I was in the office,
以及他们的工作是如何随着封锁和各种情况而改变的。是的。很有趣的是，昨天是我们公司居家办公的一周年纪念日。所以已经一年了。是的，已经一年了。这很有趣，因为我当时想，我在纽约市还有一家清洁公司。我们当时说，哦，哇，太疯狂了。已经一年了。然后我想，哦，对了，我的另一家公司也满一年了。因为我们在纽约市有一个共享办公室，我们为我的清洁公司和营销公司 Voi Media 使用同一个办公室，对吧？但确实已经一年了，这有点疯狂，因为我当时在办公室，
I guess last week doing recording for a course that we're coming out with for marketing. And it's like weird going into the office and I'm like, wow, it's crazy. I used to come here every single day. I was like, why did I do that? We're just like, why did I do that? Because now it's so much easier just to wake up and go to your office space and inside your room to do the work. So I love it. It's so much better, I think. Yeah, I feel the same way. The only thing that I think about is, would I want to come to the office like once a month or once a week or something like that? That's really the only thing that I kind of mull back and forth because yeah, going into the office every day makes zero sense now that we've seen, you know, another way of
我想是上周，在为我们即将推出的营销课程录音。走进办公室感觉很奇怪，我在想，哇，太疯狂了。我以前每天都来这里。我在想，我为什么要那样做？我们只是在想，我为什么要那样做？因为现在醒来直接走进房间里的办公空间工作要容易得多。所以我很喜欢。我认为这好多了。是的，我也这么觉得。我唯一想到的是，我是否愿意像一个月或一周去一次办公室之类的？这真的是我唯一反复思考的事情，因为是的，既然我们已经看到了另一种工作方式，每天去办公室就完全没有意义了。
doing it. Yeah. And that's the thing too. And that's why I think this working from home thing is great. And at least for me, it's funny because I used to work home all the time because my background is programming, computer science. I used to do like remote stuff all the time. It was only until I started doing like more corporate jobs. That's when I started doing like, oh, you have to be in the office. So it's funny because now I'm like, oh yeah, like this is so great. This is why I love doing programming before when I was like, because I could just work from my apartment and then do jobs for other people without ever seeing them or even meeting them. It's just like talk over the phone or through email. So I think, at least for me, I think it's great because you guys probably know like
是的，就是这样。这就是为什么我认为居家办公这件事很棒。至少对我来说，这很有趣，因为我以前一直居家办公，因为我的背景是编程和计算机科学。我以前一直做远程工作。直到我开始做一些更正式的企业工作时，才开始有那种“哦，你必须在办公室”的要求。所以这很有趣，因为现在我在想，哦，是的，这太棒了。这就是我以前喜欢编程的原因，因为我可以只在公寓里工作，然后为别人做项目，而无需见到他们，甚至无需与他们见面。只需要通过电话或电子邮件交流。所以我认为，至少对我来说，我认为这很棒，因为你们可能知道，
these big companies are always were like, no, you need to be in the office all the time or else you're never going to do anything or getting work done. I'm like, people that don't do any work, it doesn't matter where they are, office, not in the office. They're not going to get any work done no matter what, like no matter if you have 10 cameras on them. And they might make the busy people not do work too if they're in the same office. Exactly. People don't realize that because it's one of those things where you see someone not doing anything, that really permeates to the company saying, oh, if they don't care, then why should I care? Right. So it's like pretty dangerous sometimes too. Yeah. Patrick and I worked at the same company a really long time ago and at a company where they asked everyone to be in at 7.30 AM for no reason. I mean,
这些大公司总是说，不，你必须一直待在办公室，否则你永远不会做任何事情或完成工作。我觉得，那些不做工作的人，无论他们在哪里，在办公室还是不在办公室，他们都不会完成任何工作，即使你在他们身上装 10 个摄像头也没用。而且如果他们待在同一个办公室，他们甚至可能会影响那些忙碌的人也不去工作。完全正确。人们没有意识到这一点，因为当你看到有人什么都不做时，这真的会渗透到公司里，让人觉得，哦，如果他们都不在乎，那我为什么要关心呢？对吧。所以这有时也相当危险。是的。帕特里克（Patrick）和我在很久以前曾在同一家公司工作，那家公司无缘无故要求每个人在早上 7:30 到岗。我的意思是，
we were just dropping code. I mean, it was, and I couldn't, I honestly, I couldn't do it. I mean, now because I have kids, you know, Patrick has kids who were probably up at 6am just because of that. But, but as someone who was in college, I just could not do it. And I remember getting in trouble and like, I just didn't have the willpower to really do that. And finally, I think they just kind of swept it under the rug. It's like, okay, this person's going to come in at like 830, nine o'clock and we'll just deal with it. But yeah, a lot of these rules, you know, when you really step back and this has kind of forced us. But yeah, a lot of these rules, you know, when you really step back and this has kind of forced us to step back,
我们当时只是在写代码。我的意思是，我真的做不到。现在因为我有孩子了，你知道，帕特里克也有孩子，我们可能因为这个 6 点就起床了。但是，作为一个大学生，我真的做不到。我记得我因此惹了麻烦，我真的没有意志力去那样做。最后，我想他们只是把这件事掩盖过去了。就像是，好吧，这个人会在 8:30 或 9 点左右进来，我们就凑合着处理吧。但确实，很多这样的规则，当你真正退后一步审视时，这在某种程度上迫使我们退后一步，
you realize that the rules ultimately were made by regular people and often, you know, 50 years ago. And so we really need to revisit them. Yeah. And that's the thing, like all these rules of like, hey, you got to be working nine to five. It's just like crazy because,
你会意识到这些规则最终是由普通人制定的，而且通常是 50 年前制定的。所以我们真的需要重新审视它们。是的，就是这样，所有这些关于“嘿，你必须朝九晚五工作”的规则，简直太疯狂了，因为，
I mean, similar to you guys, programmers, like sometimes like you work better at night when it's just like better time for you to think, better time for you to do whatever you're in the day. And it's kind of crazy because you always hear about people with like productivity. It's like, hey, you got to be like productive in the morning and, you know, work out. I'm like, if you're working nine to five, like you can't do that. You need like a good three hours. Like why doesn't it work? Like maybe you start work at 12, you know, and then end at eight. Because that way in the morning, you can get all this stuff that you need to get done. Like, you know, working out, eating well, cooking for your family, all the stuff that you need in order to like
我的意思是，和你们一样，程序员有时在晚上工作效率更高，因为那是你思考的最佳时间，也是你做任何事情的最佳时间。这很疯狂，因为你总是听到人们谈论生产力。就像是，嘿，你必须在早上保持高效，并且锻炼身体。我说，如果你朝九晚五工作，你根本做不到。你需要整整三个小时。为什么不行呢？也许你 12 点开始工作，然后 8 点结束。因为这样在早上，你可以完成所有你需要做的事情。比如，锻炼、吃得好、为家人做饭，所有你需要做的事情，为了
have an actual productive day because you work nine to five, you wake up at six, commute for an hour, and then you're back home at 7 p.m. And you're like, okay, what am I supposed to do? Cook, work out, talk to my family, watch TV, like, and then be bed by 10 p.m.? Like, how is that possible in like three hours, right? Yeah, and what am I supposed to do? Cook, work out, talk to my family, watch TV, like, and then be bad by 10 PM. Like, how is that possible in like three hours, right?
拥有真正高效的一天。因为如果你朝九晚五工作，你 6 点起床，通勤一小时，然后晚上 7 点回到家。你会想，好吧，我该做什么？做饭、锻炼、和家人聊天、看电视，然后 10 点睡觉？这在三个小时内怎么可能实现，对吧？是的，而且其他人也都在同一时间尝试做这些事，这让一切变得更难。就像你去杂货店，那里挤满了人。你知道，一切都很忙。是的。另一件事是，而且我知道营销方面肯定也是一样，它是有起伏的。
Yeah, and everyone else is trying to do it at the same time too, which makes everything harder. It's like, you go to the grocery store, it's packed. You know, everything's busy. Yeah. The other thing too is, and you know, I'm sure it's the same with marketing, is it ebbs and flows.
就像可能有一个月你刚从客户那里拿到 API，现在你必须实现它。而且，你知道，他们在等你。然后可能有一个月你刚从客户那里拿到 API，现在你必须实现它，而且，你知道，他们在等你。然后有一个月你只是在等他们。所以，你知道，能够跨越几个月保持灵活性，有些周你工作 30 小时，有些周你工作 100 小时。现在我认为这比
Like there's maybe a month where you just got the API from the customer and now you have to implement it. And, you know, they're waiting on you. And then there's maybe a month where you just got the API from the customer and now you have to implement it and, and, you know, they're waiting on you. And then there's a whole month where you're just waiting on them. And so, and so, you know, being able to be flexible over the span of months where some weeks you work 30 hours, some weeks you work a hundred hours. Now that, that I think is much healthier than, yeah,
朝九晚五进来，而且在事情非常忙的时候仍然承受压力，但当不忙的时候你仍然必须来，这要健康得多，对吧？是的。是的，完全正确。这很有趣，因为我认为即使对于我的公司，我也看到有些人，有些月份他们简直超级高效，而有些月份他们只是在做他们需要做的工作。然后我就想，是的，人都有情绪。我的意思是，你们可能知道，当你正在进行一个新的编程项目或一个新的想法时，你非常兴奋，以至于你只想一直做下去。然后你进入那个瓶颈期，比如，哦，我还要做那个项目吗？然后你就失去了一点动力，
you come in nine to five and you still are under the gun when things are really busy, but when they're not busy, you just have to come anyways, right? Yeah. Yeah, exactly. And it's funny because I think even for my company, I see that some people are like, some months they're just like crazy productive and some months they're just kind of like, just working like what they need to work. And then I'm just like, yeah, people have their moods. I mean, you guys probably know, like when you're working on a new programming project or a new idea, you're just so excited that like, you just want to keep working on it all the time. And then you go into that hump of like, oh, should I do that project anymore? And then you just like lose motivation for a little
然后你又兴奋起来，然后你又买了一个域名。你就像，好吧，这就是那个项目。然后你就像，这就是我要做的项目。然后就像整个循环一样。是的。我的天哪，你说到点子上了。然后你就像，这就是我想做的项目。然后就像整个循环一样。是的。我的天哪，你说到点子上了。我有很多，我前几天买了 juggler.ai。
bit and then you get excited and then you buy another domain name. You're like, okay, this is the project. And then you're like, this is the project I'm going to do. And then it's like that whole cycle. Yeah. I mean, oh my gosh, you hit the nail on the head. I then you're like, this is the project I want to do. And then it's like that whole cycle. Yeah. I mean, oh my gosh, you hit the nail on the head. I have so many, I bought juggler.ai the other day.
是的，我有很多，每一个域名，每一个想法都花了我，你知道，我不知道，是多少？10 美元还是什么的？
And yeah, I have so many, every domain name, every idea costs me, you know, I don't know, what is it? $10 or something?
因为我会想出一个域名，然后，你知道，90% 的想法什么都没发生，但你最终得到了所有这些域名。最棒的是，至少对我来说，我看到一个域名，比如 Namecheap 发来邮件说，你的域名过期了。我就想，哦，对了，那是一年前的好主意。
Because I'll come up with a domain name and then, you know, 90% of those ideas, nothing happens, but you end up with all these domain names. The best is like, at least for me, like I see a domain name, like Namecheap, like your domain name expired. I'm like, oh yeah, that was a good idea a year ago.
我还是会那样做。不错。那么给我们讲讲你的故事吧。你以前是一名程序员，现在经营着 Voi Media，我想你说还有一家自助洗衣店或清洁公司。所以，是的，给我们讲讲整个故事。我的意思是，这听起来是一个非常非常有趣的故事。是的。
I was like, I still do that. Nice. So tell us a bit about your story. So you used to be a programmer and you're running, you know, Voi Media and I think you said a laundromat or a cleaning business. So, yeah, tell us that whole story. I mean, that sounds like a really, really interesting story. Yeah.
所以基本上，我想你们做编程。我的背景实际上是计算机科学。所以我是在纽约州北部上的学，我学的是 CS。基本上，我学 CS 的原因是因为在成长过程中，我非常喜欢电子游戏。我喜欢玩电子游戏，就像大多数人一样。是的。等等，你玩什么游戏？我很好奇。
So basically, I guess you guys do programming. My background is actually in computer science. So I went to school in upstate New York and I did CS. Basically, the reason why I did CS was because growing up, I was really big into video games. I love playing video games, like I guess most people. Yeah. So wait, what games did you play? I'm curious.
我以前玩过一个叫《战争秘密》（Secrets of War）的游戏。我不确定你们是否听说过。哦，我从来没听说过那个。哦，听起来很棒。这个游戏太棒了。它真的是让我开始思考什么是编程或计算机东西的游戏。因为在那个时候，那是 15、16 年前，我刚得到我的第一台
I used to play this game called Secrets of War. I'm not sure if you guys heard of it. Oh, I've never heard of that one. Oh, it sounds awesome. This game was awesome. Like it was literally the game that got me into like thinking about what programming or computer stuff was. Because at this time, it was like 15, 15 16 years ago like i just got my first
电脑，那是一台旧的康柏（Compaq），你知道那些巨大的屏幕，对吧？哦，是的，是的。我得到它是为了因为我的邻居为我们买的，呃，这是很久以前的事了，我们当时很穷。然后我就想，哦，这太酷了，互联网刚出现，我们学会了 AOL，你得到了那些光盘，对吧？这就像，哦，是的，我喜欢这个游戏，因为它真的向我展示了在线什么是可能的。我从来不知道，直到我玩这个游戏，我给开发者发了电子邮件，我想这至少对我来说展示了开发者社区是什么样的。我给他发了电子邮件，他是一个我想是在荷兰的人，我当时问，嘿，你是怎么制作这个东西，这个游戏的？他
computer it was like a old compact like you know those massive screens right oh yeah yeah yeah and i got that because my neighbor purchased it for us uh this is like a long time ago we were pretty poor and then i was like oh this is so cool like internet just came up we learned aol you got those discs right it's just like oh yeah it's like I love this game because it really showed me like what was possible online I never I never knew about that until like I was playing this game and I emailed the developer and I guess this shows you at least for me kind of how the developer community was I emailed him and he was this guy in I think Netherlands or and I was like hey how do you make this thing this game and he's
说，哦，我用 C# 编程，那在当时是一回事，对吧？C#，哦，是的，没错。所以我当时想，哦，天哪，这太疯狂了。然后他说，但你可能应该先学习 HTML。所以我开始学习《傻瓜式 HTML》，这就是我真正开始的地方。然后我开始非常热衷于学习 Photoshop，对吧？因为我在论坛上，我不确定你们是否记得论坛过去有
like oh i programmed in like c sharp that was like a thing back then right c sharp oh yeah that's right yeah so i was like oh my god this is crazy i was like and then i was like he's like but you should probably learn like html first so then i started learning html for dummies and that's really kind of how i got started in and then i got really big into like just learning photoshop right because i was on the forums and like i'm not sure if you guys remember forums used to have of how I got started in. And then I got really big into like just learning Photoshop, right? Because I was on the forums and like, I'm not sure if you guys remember forums used to have like signatures where you can add like custom stuff. Oh yeah. I remember that. And then there would be the, uh, the automated signature where it would take like your level from wow. And it
签名，你可以添加自定义的东西。哦，是的，我记得。然后会有自动签名，它会获取你在《魔兽世界》中的等级，并把它做成一张图片。是的，完全正确。所以那些东西对我来说太有趣了。所以我开始为人们做那些东西。那就是我学习 Photoshop 的时候。然后我就想，好吧，我得学习如何破解 Photoshop。然后我学会了使用种子（Torrents）。你进入了这个充满东西的世界，你会想，哦，天哪，这太疯狂了。这太有趣和令人兴奋了。所以这就是我做这件事的方式。我记得我去了这个叫 Komodo Media 的网站。我不确定你们是否知道，但这个叫 Raji King 的人。
would make a image out of it. Yeah, exactly. So that stuff was so fun for me. So I started doing those for people. And that's when I learned about Photoshop. And I was like, okay, well, I got to learn how to crack Photoshop. And then I learned to Torrents. And you go into this world of stuff that wears that you're like, oh my God, this is so crazy. This is so fun and exciting. So that's kind of how I did it. And I remember going to this website called Komodo Media. I'm not sure if you guys know, but this guy named Raji King.
不，我从来没听说过。他的名字在推特上叫 Raji。他制作了一个非常酷的网站，是丛林主题的。在侧边栏上，有一个小开关，如果你来回切换它，他网站上的叶子就会生长。它非常像动画。我当时想，哇，这太酷了。是的。这听起来和我看到的另一个网站很像，就在 Flash 变得非常流行的时候，你进入网站，它只是一个空白屏幕。突然一个标志就会出现在屏幕上并开始旋转。当你习惯了，你知道，PHP，那种零 JavaScript 的网站，
No, I never heard of it. His name is like Raji on Twitter. And he made this really cool website that was, it was like jungle theme. And on the sidebar, it had like a little toggle that if you toggle it back and forth, the leaves on his website would grow. And it was like very like animated. I was like, whoa, this is so cool. Yeah. That sounds similar to another website I saw, which like right when flash was becoming like pretty popular, like you'd go to the website and it was just a blank screen. And all of a sudden a logo would just appear out of the screen and start spinning. And when you're used to like, you know, PHP, like zero JavaScript websites,
或者你点击一个复选框，整个网站就会刷新，当你习惯了那个，你看到这个，就像，天哪。我简直不敢相信这是可能的。完全正确。而且这太有趣了，因为 Flash，我记得学习 ActionScript，那就是你制作 Flash 东西的方式。是的，这太疯狂了。所以基本上，正如人们所看到的，这些东西真的让我很兴奋。然后这引导我进入了，无论如何，回到 Raji。这太疯狂了，因为我在大约 17 岁时给他发了电子邮件，他竟然回复了我。我当时想，哇，这太疯狂了。他真的教我，嘿，是的，这是一个非常适合你的职业领域。你应该学习 HTML 和 CSS。
or like you'd, you'd click a checkbox and the whole website would refresh when you're used to that. And you see this, it's like, holy cow. I couldn't believe that was possible. Exactly. And that's, it's so funny because flash, I remember learning action script and that's how you made like flash stuff. And yeah, it's like so crazy. Like all, so basically like, as people see like this stuff really excited me. And then that led me into, for anyways, back to Raji. This is like crazy because I emailed him when I was like maybe 17 years old and he actually responded to me. And I was like, whoa, this is crazy. He like literally taught me like, Hey, yeah, this is a great career field for you. And you should learn HTML and CSS.
而且我实际上在几个月前，我在推特上给他发了消息说，嘿，顺便说一下，你算是帮助我开启了编程生涯。这很疯狂，因为他可能没想过。一封随机的电子邮件真的可以塑造一个人的未来。我认为这正是你们也在做的事情。有时你只需要听到有人告诉你，是的，去做吧。这很疯狂，因为他真的只是告诉我，是的，去学习 HTML 和 CSS。这就是我开始更多地做这件事的方式，因为我看到了他的网站。是的，那是一个非常非常感人的故事。是的。它展示了每一次互动是多么重要。是的，就像，你甚至不知道，因为他可能不知道。然后
And I actually like maybe a few months ago, I actually messaged him on Twitter and say, Hey, by the way, like you kind of helped me start my career in programming. And it's crazy because he probably didn't think about it. A random email could really shape someone's future. And I think that's kind of what you guys are doing too. Sometimes you just need to hear somebody tell you, yeah, go do that. And it's crazy because he literally just told me, yeah, go learn HTML and CSS. And that's kind of how I got started even more into doing it because I saw his website. Yeah. That's, that's a really, really touching story. Yeah. It shows how important like every single interaction is. Yeah. And it's like, you don't even know it because he probably didn't know it. And then
就像，哦，是的，这就是，我发现的原因是因为，哦，是的，我喜欢给他们发电子邮件，我查看了我旧的 Gmail 账户。我当时想，哦，天哪，这封邮件里的语法和英语太疯狂了。我甚至不知道他为什么要回复。但无论如何，这就是我开始编程的方式。但这种编程引导我学习了更多关于初创公司的知识，因为在那个时候，硅谷是一个热门话题，对吧？Facebook 刚刚出现。谷歌是一家巨大的公司。MySpace，对吧，在那个时候非常大。这就是我开始学习更多编程的原因，因为我当时想，哦，MySpace，对吧？它在那个时候非常大。这就是我开始学习更多编程的原因，因为我当时想，哦，所有这些科技公司都在赚
it was like, oh yeah, like this is, and I, the reason why I found out was because it was like, oh yeah, I like emailed them and I looked through my old Gmail account. I was like, oh my God, like this grammar and English in this email is so crazy. I don't even know why he responded. But anyways, that's kind of how I got started into programming. But this sort of programming led me into learning more about startups in general, because at this time, Silicon Valley was a thing, right? Facebook was just coming out. Google was this massive company. MySpace, right, was really big at that time. And that's kind of how I started learning more programming because I was like, oh, MySpace, right? It was really big at that time. And that's kind of how I started learning more programming because I was like, oh, all these tech companies are making all
这么多钱。我记得，我不确定你们是否记得，Digg 当时刚出来，对吧？凯文·罗斯（Kevin Rose）。哦，是的，我记得 Digg。它们还在吗？所以我认为它们被另一家公司收购了，但它们不是以前的那个 Digg 了，对吧？所以，是的。但这就像那个时代，我想你们可能记得，我想它被称为 Web 2.0，对吧？Web 2.0，是的，是的，就是那样，没错。所以就像 1.0 是，你知道，点击一个复选框，整个东西刷新，2.0 是你真正拥有这种 Flash JavaScript 革命的地方，是的，现在我们处于 3.0，就像你只是通过网络发送数据。是的。也许。是的。2.0 就像，它叫什么？Ajax 刚出来。记得吗？就像，
these money. I remember, I'm not sure if you guys remember, like Dig just came out at the time, right? Kevin Rose. Oh yeah. I remember Dig. Are they still around? So I think they got acquired by another company, but they're not like the same Dig as before, right? So like, yeah. But this is like that time that error of like i guess i guess you probably remember i think it was called like web 2.0 right like web 2.0 yeah yeah it's like that yeah that's right so it's like like 1.0 was the you know yeah click a checkbox whole thing refreshes 2.0 is where you really have this kind of like flash javascript kind of revolution yeah and yeah now we're in 3.0 where it's like you're just sending data over the wire. Yeah. Yeah. Maybe. Yeah. 2.0 was like, what's it called? Ajax just came out. Remember? Like,
人们当时想，哦，天哪，Ajax。是的，没错。Ajax 太酷了。它是 jQuery 让它变得如此容易做的事情。而且，你正在编写 jQuery 代码，它就像意大利面条代码，到处都是调用。简直是疯狂的东西。是的。我们请了 Guillermo Rauch 来节目谈论 Next.js，我们当时在回忆 Web 2.0，那真是一场彻底的灾难。在某种程度上，它实际上让你作为一名 Web 程序员更有价值，因为它太难了。哦，是的。这太真实了。我现在看编程，我在想，人们没有意识到，回到那时，我们是在为浏览器中的怪癖编写代码。
people were like, oh my God, Ajax. Yeah, that's right. Ajax is so cool. It was like a thing that jQuery made it so easy to do. And like, you're writing jQuery code and it was like spaghetti code, like just calls everywhere. Just like crazy stuff. Yeah. We had Guillermo Rauch on the show to talk about Next.js and we were kind of reminiscing of Web 2.0 and what a total disaster it was. In a way, it's like, it actually made you more valuable as a web programmer because it was so hard. Oh yeah. It was so true. I look at programming now, I'm like, people don't realize like back then we were like coding for like quirks in the browser.
那是一个疯狂的时代。是的。你知道，有人前几天提到这一点，他们谈论他们如何感觉，哦，我希望我早点出生，这样我就可以自己开发 Atari 游戏，并发布游戏，那只是我和一个艺术家。但是，问题是，是的，你会花费，你知道，也许 1500 小时试图让游戏适应卡带。而现在，你只需要打开 Unity。是的，完全正确。但无论如何，所以基本上有了所有这些东西，正如你所看到的，我当时很感兴趣，所以我对很多东西都很感兴趣。我认为当你年轻的时候，你应该对很多事情感兴趣，因为你不知道你真正喜欢什么，直到后来。即使那样，知道比
Like that was a crazy time. Yeah. You know, someone mentioned this the other day, they were talking about how they felt like, oh, I wish, you know, I was born earlier so I could work on the Atari games by myself and like release the game, which is me and an artist. But, but the thing is, is yeah, you would spend, you know, you know, maybe a 1500 hours trying to get the game to fit on the cartridge. Whereas now it's like, you just open up unity. Yeah, exactly. But anyways, so that's kind of, so basically with all this stuff, like, as you can see, I was like, so I was interested in so much stuff back. And I think as when you're young, you should be interested in a ton of things because you don't know what you really like until later on. And even then, like, it's always good to just know more than
人们告诉你你应该知道的更多，总是好的，对吧？我只是好奇。所以我真的开始做初创公司了。那时我只是在构建东西。我正在制作我自己的 Twitter 克隆，我自己的 MySpace 克隆。我当时想，哦，如果我构建这些东西，也许我会让人使用我的产品，对吧？这就是我开始构建软件的地方。而且，我在这里学到的是，我非常信奉“如果你构建它，他们就会来”的口号。这就是科技界人士所说的，嘿，如果你有一个伟大的产品，客户就会找到你。从来没有真正接触过营销。我当时想，我一直认为营销很糟糕，意思是，嘿，如果你做营销，那就意味着你的产品很烂。因为那是我在网上读到的。而且
people tell you you should know, right? I was just curious. So I was really starting to do startups. And that's when I was kind of just building things at this time. I was making my own Twitter clone, my own MySpace clone. And I was like, oh, if I build this stuff, maybe I'll get people to use my products, right? And that's kind of where I started just building software. And really, what I've learned around here was that I was really big into this mantra of, if you build it, they will come. And that's kind of what tech people were saying, hey, if you have a great product, customers will find you. Never into really marketing. I was like, I always thought marketing was bad as in, hey, if you do marketing, that means your product sucks. Because that's what I read online. And
那就像，只是理论。是的。我的意思是，这是一种非常自然的冲动。就像营销感觉像是，我也曾有同样的感觉，你知道，直到我真正了解它，营销感觉像是，你知道，说服某人做某事，就像，好吧，人们应该做对他们自然的事情。所以这就是你的第一直觉。然后你思考一下，你会想，好吧，想想你做的所有事情，以及你是从哪里发现这些事情的。对吧。而且老实说，如果你也考虑一下，比如 Slack，每个人，这就像一个常见的 Slack，几乎很多人都在使用 Slack，每个人都说，哦，Slack 如此占主导地位是因为它有网络效应，是的，所有这些都是真的，但如果你也考虑 Slack，他们可能有 50
that's sort of like, just like the theory. Yeah. I mean, that is a very, like, that's a very natural impulse. It's like marketing feels like, and I felt the same way, you know, until I really learned more about it is marketing feels like, you know, convincing someone to do something and it's like, well, people should do what's natural to them. And so that's, that's kind of your first instinct. And then you, then you kind of think about it and you're like, well, think about all the things you do and where you found out about those things. Right. And doing and and honestly if you think about it too like like slack for example everybody this is like a common slack almost a lot of people use slack and everybody's like oh slack so dominant because it's like natural effects and it's like network effects and oh yes all that's true but if you think about slack too they have like maybe 50
个营销人员在他们的团队中，他们不是什么都不做，他们不是什么都不做。他们正在做品牌推广。他们正在做外联。他们正在给大公司打电话。他们正在给小公司打电话。所以即使是那些看起来很自然的大公司，他们也知道为了真正成长并让他们的业务走出去，你需要营销人员。而且 Slack 在传达
marketers on their team they're not doing nothing they're not doing nothing. They're like doing the branding. They're doing the outreach. They're calling big companies. They're calling small companies. So even big companies that somehow seem natural, they know that in order to truly grow and get their business out there, you need marketing people. And Slack does a good job of like conveying
它只是自然增长方面做得很好，但任何上市公司，或者 Slack 是一家上市公司，我想他们被 Salesforce 收购了。他们知道他们需要营销。当然，然后说，所以我不知道。这就是为什么，这就是我思考它的原因。就像，如果你真的想发展你的公司，你确实需要某种营销。至少它不需要是骗人的或类似的东西。它只需要对你作为企业主来说是可预测的，因为你想要能够知道，我如何才能引入新客户以维持我的业务和我的员工？
that it's just like a natural growth, but any public company or Slack's a public company, I think they're acquired by Salesforce. They know that they need marketing. And of course, then say, so I don't know. That's why, that's why I think about it. It's like, if you truly want to grow your company, you sort of need some sort of marketing. At least it doesn't need to be scammy or anything like that. It just needs to be predictable for you as a business owner, because you want to be able to know, how can I bring in new customers in order to maintain my business and my employees?
所以这就是，但无论如何，回到我做营销的那个故事，我搬到了硅谷，然后我开始为 mint.com 工作。所以我在 Mint 做前端开发，根本不是营销。我在那里待了不到一年。我待了不到一年的原因是因为我不喜欢我在 Mint 做的事情。我以为它会是一家科技初创公司。在那个时候，它对我来说非常企业化。Mint 被 Intuit 收购了。我只是觉得这不是我来这里的原因。所以几个月后我离开了，我回去为 Zarly 工作。Zarly 就像一家筹集了大量资金的科技初创公司。
So that's sort of like, but anyways, going back to like that story of me doing marketing, I moved out to Silicon Valley and then I started working for mint.com. So I was at mint doing front end development, not marketing at all. I was there for about less than a year. And the reason why I was there for less than a year is because I didn't like what I was doing at mint. I thought it was going to be like a tech startup. It was very corporate for me at that time. Mint got acquired by Intuit. And I just felt like this isn't what I came out here for. So then I left after a few months and I went back to work to Zarly. And Zarly was like a tech startup that raised a bunch of money.
这就是我开始更多地接触营销的地方，因为我被调到了 Zarly 的营销部门。所以我当时和一位叫 Lou Chen 的女士一起工作，她说，嘿，我们需要帮助安装所有这些用于跟踪、营销电子邮件、个性化内容的标签。这就是我当时觉得，哦，哇，营销竟然是这样，这太疯狂了。我当时想，这有点像编程，对吧？个性化有点像你在编程一些东西，数据库，你提取用户名，你看看他们对什么感兴趣，然后你把它们拉进一封电子邮件中，这就像 HTML，就像一个网页，对吧？这就是我发现有趣的地方，就是，哦，所有
And this is where I kind of got more into marketing because I was put into the marketing department in Zarly. So I was working with this lady called Lou Chen and she was like, hey, we need help installing all these tags for tracking, for marketing emails, for personalized stuff. And this is when for me at that time was like, oh wow, it's crazy that this is marketing. I was like, this is kind of just like programming, right? It's like personalization is kind of like you're programming some of the stuff, the database, you're pulling out the usernames, you're seeing what they're interested in, and then you're pulling into like an email, which is just like HTML, like a webpage, right? And then that's why I found interesting was that like, oh, all
这些营销人员，他们真的受到他们能力的限制，因为他们不知道如何编程，对吧？所以这就是我的想法，对吧？这就是我进入的方式。这和数字营销与常规营销有什么不同？所以，我的意思是，我想即使是常规营销，你也有一个数据库，你也有某种个性化。只是你可能有一个额外的步骤，你必须打印一封信并寄给某人。你觉得我们收到的那种营销（比如门口的传单）和数字营销之间真正的巨大区别是什么？
these marketers, like they're really limited by their ability because they don't know how to program it, right? So that was like my thought, right? And that's how I got into. How is that different than like digital versus regular? So, I mean, I imagine even with regular marketing, you have a database and you have some kind of personalization. It's just that you have maybe this extra step where you have to like print a letter and send it to somebody. What would you feel like is the real big difference there between, you know, the kind of marketing that we get, you know, on our doorstep and digital marketing?
是的，我认为最大的……是的，这是一个好问题。对于数字营销，它有点像，我猜，邮件或直邮营销。我认为区别在于没有那么多的个性化。这是目前正在出现的一件大事。你们听说过一点，新的 iOS 更新，谷歌和 Facebook 正在扼杀所有个性化广告。但最大的区别在于，以好或坏的方式，这取决于人们如何看待它。你现在在网上看到的广告对你来说更个性化。所以这是人们认为的，这是我们认为的，嘿，你可能喜欢这个，或者我们认为
Yeah, I think the biggest... Yeah, that's a good question. With digital marketing, it's sort of like, I guess, mail or direct mail marketing for your mailman. I think what's the difference is that there's not that much personalization. And that's something that's a big thing coming up right now. You guys have heard a bit, the new iOS update, Google and Facebook killing all personalization ads. But the biggest difference is in a good or bad way, it just depends on how people think about it. Ads that you see online right now are more personalized to you. So it's stuff that people think, it's stuff that we think, hey, you might like this, or we think
你可能对这个感兴趣，而不是像门口的邮件。这有点像，这是一个自由竞争，就像，嘿，也许你需要这个东西。这就是为什么人们把营销与垃圾邮件联系在一起，因为他们习惯了邮件里塞满了各种你可能不知道的优惠。是的，这说得通。我想你需要一定的规模经济，对吧？就像你必须，如果你要打印，字面意思上打印出营销材料并邮寄给某人，你不能让打印机为每个人做不同的事情。这在成本上是不划算的。所以你最终就像每个人都得到尿布广告。不管他们是谁？他们都会得到一张尿布优惠券。
you might be interested in this versus like mail on the door. It's kind of like, it's a, it's a free for all where it's like, Hey, maybe you'll need this thing. And so that's why people associate marketing with spam because they're used to like the mail coming in with like all sorts of offers that you might not know about. Yeah, that makes sense. I guess you, you need like a certain economy of scale, right? Like you have to, um, if you're going to print out, like literally print out the marketing and mail it to somebody, you're going to print out, like literally print out the marketing and mail it to somebody, you can't have the printer do something different for each person. It's just not cost effective. And so you end up just like everybody gets diapers. Like, does it matter who they are? They get a coupon for diapers.
但是的，完全正确。这就是数字邮件和实体邮件之间最大的区别。这就是为什么 Facebook 在刚出来时如此具有革命性，因为他们长期以来一直在跟踪一切。你们记得 Facebook 刚出来时有“赞”吗？记得那个赞按钮或什么的？哦，就像在不同的网站上，你可以赞某样东西。是的，是的。那是他们对个性化的第一次洞察。
But yeah, exactly. And that's the biggest difference between digital and physical mail. And that's why like Facebook was so revolutionary when it first came out because they were just tracking everything from a long time. You guys remember when Facebook first came out with like likes, remember that like button or whatever? Oh, like on different websites, you could like something. Yeah, yeah. That was like their first sort of like insight into personalization.
如果考虑到这一点，那是一个伟大的特洛伊木马，因为他们只是说，嘿，让我们在每个页面上放这个按钮，人们会告诉我们他们喜欢什么。然后我们将使用它来构建一个数据库，一个数据集，对吧？是的，这说得通。所以，是的，我的意思是，因为它只是，你知道，
And that was a great Trojan horse, if you think about it, because they're just like, hey, let's get this button every page and people will tell us what they like. And then we'll use that to build a database, a data set, right? Yeah, that makes sense. And so, yeah, I mean, since it's just like, you know,
能量的噼啪声而不是纸上的墨水，你可以，是的，正如你所说的，你可以给每个人发送不同的广告。是的，完全正确。这就是数字营销，这就是数字营销和其他营销之间最大的区别。但回到，就像，只是思考一般的营销，你在邮件中收到的那种营销，那些做那种营销的人
crackles of energy and not ink on paper, you could just, yeah, as you said, you could send a different ad to each person. Yeah, exactly. And that's why digital marketing is, that's the biggest difference between digital marketing and like the other marketing. But going back with like, kind of like just thinking about marketing in general, like the marketing that you would get in the mail, those guys doing those type of marketings
是伟大的营销人员。如果人们正在考虑学习营销，那些就是你想研究的人，因为他们发送给你的文案和那种艺术品需要转化，因为就像你刚才说的，这是一种“喷洒和祈祷”（广撒网）。所以你正在写一些最好的文案，因为你试图说服某人他们需要这个，
were great marketers. If people are thinking about studying marketing, those are the people you want to study because that copy and that sort of artwork that they send you needs to convert because kind of what you just said before, it's a spray and pray. So you're writing some of the best copy because you're trying to convince somebody they need this
即使他们认为他们可能不需要它。是的，这说得通。所以你在 mint.com。对于不知道的人，Mint 是，我想，如果我错了请纠正我，但它是一种跟踪你财务状况的方式，对吧？是的。然后他们被 Intuit 收购了。
even though they think they might not need it. Yeah, that makes sense. So you're at mint.com. For people who don't know, Mint was, I think, correct me if I'm wrong, but it's some way to like track your finances, right? Yep. And so they got acquired by Intuit.
现在实际上我最近完成了我的 TurboTax。实际上，我正在帮助我的父母完成他们的 TurboTax。在最后，有一个类似 Mint 的插件。就像在 Mint 上继续。所以，是的，那次收购现在完全说得通了。但后来你去了，
And now actually I recently completed my Turbo. Actually, I was helping out my parents complete their Turbo tax. And at the end, there was sort of like a plug for Mint. It's like continue on Mint. And so, yeah, that acquisition actually makes a ton of sense now. But then you went to,
你能提醒我那之后的初创公司名字吗？它叫 Zarly，Z-A-R-L-Y。那么 Zarly 是做什么的？所以 Zarly 就像，基本上在开始时，他们是一个平台，你可以在上面请求任何东西。把它想象成当年的“万能版 Uber Eats”。哦，有趣。所以它是像木匠、油漆工之类的东西，还是送餐？完善了这些，然后继续做更多。有点像 Uber 试图做 Postmates。他们都在试图建立这个网络。然后就像，嘿，顺便说一下，看，我们可以做任何事情。
can you remind me the name of the startup after that? It was called Zarly, Z-A-R-L-Y. So what did Zarly do? So Zarly was kind of like, basically in the beginning, there were this platform for, you could request anything on them. Think about it as kind of like Uber Eats for anything back in the day. Oh, interesting. So is it like carpenter, painter type stuff or is it food delivery? perfected those and then gone on to more. Kind of like Uber's trying to do Postmates. They're all trying to build this network. And then it's like, hey, by the way, look, we can do everything.
有点像亚马逊模式，他们从书开始，然后就像，现在是所有东西，对吧？是的，这说得通。在《从 0 到 1》中，彼得·蒂尔（Peter Thiel）谈到了这一点，你如何想要拥有一个……拥有一个小垄断比……我想在他的例子中，他说拥有一个小垄断比成为一家航空公司要好。即使航空公司是巨大的，因为它不是垄断，
Kind of like the Amazon model where they start off with books and then it's like, now it's everything, right? Yeah, that makes sense. In Zero to One, Peter Thiel talks about this, how you want to have a... It's better to have a small monopoly than to be... I think in his example, he says it's better to have a small monopoly than to be, I think in his example, he says, it's better to have a small monopoly than an airline. Even though an airline is giant, because it's not a monopoly,
竞争太激烈了。他们实际上并没有赚那么多利润。所以是的，我认为这完全说得通。所以你在营销部门，但你是一名工程师。这确实是你第一次深入了解营销的地方。是的，完全正确。这就是，你第一次深入了解营销的地方。是的，完全正确。
there's so much competition. They actually don't make that much profit. So yeah, I think that totally makes sense. And so you were in the marketing department, but you're an engineer. And that's really where you got your first kind of deep dive into marketing. Yeah, exactly. And that's kind of where, your first kind of deep dive into marketing. Yeah, exactly.
这就是……对我来说也是如此，这说得通，因为……我认为我在其中建立了一些联系，因为 Zarly 是一家资金充足的公司，我们得到了大量的钱，我想超过 1000 万美元。我当时只是想，哇，这个产品相当不错，对吧？我当时想，我们拥有的东西很好，因为我们在制作它。我会说也许我有偏见，但我认为我们拥有的东西真的很好。好的网站，好的设计师。我们有一个好的结账流程，但我们无法获得客户。
And that's kind of where... And that thing for me too, it made sense because... And there's a few things that I think I made connections in this because Zorli was a well-funded company and we got tons of money, I think over $10 million. And I was just like, wow, this product's pretty good, right? I was like, what we have is good because we were making it. And I would say maybe I was biased, but I thought what we had was really good. Good website, good designers. We had a good checkout, but we couldn't get customers.
所以这打破了“嘿，你有一个伟大的产品，人们就会来”的神话。我当时想，哦，也许这不是真的，对吧？然后这就是我开始更多地学习，什么是这个营销东西的时候。也许我们确实需要它，因为我开始研究竞争对手。例如，我们的一个竞争对手是 Thumbtack。我当时想，哇，这些家伙通过 SEO 增长得非常快。让我去读一下。因为人们，我一直告诉品牌，如果你想看看公司是如何增长的，试着谷歌一下 CEO 的名字。有时他们会做关于他们如何增长的演讲。所以这是一个获得业务如何运作洞察的好方法。所以 Thumbtack 的 CEO
So then that kind of like dispelled the myth of, hey, you have a great product, people will come. And I was like, oh, maybe it's not true, right? And then that's kind of when I started learning more about like, what is this marketing thing? Maybe we do need it because I started looking into competitors. Like for example, a competitor of us was like Thumbtack. And I was like, wow, these guys are really growing really fast with like SEO. Let me go read about it. Because people, I tell brands all the time, if you want to see how companies are growing, just try to Google the CEO's name. Sometimes they do like talks about how they're growing. So that's a great way to get insights into how the business is doing. So the ceo of thumbtack
所以这在某种程度上打破了“只要产品好，客户自然来”的神话。我当时想，哦，也许这不是真的，对吧？也就是在那时，我开始更多地了解什么是市场营销。也许我们确实需要它，因为我开始研究竞争对手。比如，我们的竞争对手之一是 Thumbtack。我当时心想，哇，这些人通过 SEO 发展得真快。让我去读读相关内容。因为我总是告诉品牌方，如果你想了解公司是如何发展的，试着去谷歌一下 CEO 的名字。有时他们会谈论自己的增长方式。所以，这是深入了解企业经营状况的好方法。所以 Thumbtack 的 CEO
i think was like talking about seo and i was like oh maybe we should look into seo and then that's kind of that's like that was like i first like deep dive into like what is a marketing tactic or marketing thing to do right yeah that makes sense so just some background for folks seo is is search engine optimization and uh that's about where my knowledge ends. So maybe actually, Kevin, we have you on the show. Can you dive into like, yeah, how does SEO actually, I mean, I understand the point. The point is to kind of when someone searches for maybe food delivery that they would get Zarly first, right? And not Uber Eats. I mean, that's the premise. Like how does that actually work?
我想当时是在谈论SEO，我就想，哦，也许我们应该研究一下SEO，那大概就是我第一次深入了解什么是营销策略或营销手段，对吧？是的，这很有道理。所以，为了给听众一些背景知识，SEO就是搜索引擎优化，我的知识也就到此为止了。所以，凯文，既然你来到了节目中，你能深入讲讲SEO到底是怎么运作的吗？我的意思是，我理解它的目的。目的是当有人搜索比如“送餐”时，他们会先看到Zarly，对吧？而不是Uber Eats。我的意思是，前提是这样的。那它实际上是怎么运作的呢？
Mechanically, what is done to make that happen? Yeah. So yeah, SEO is basically, for people listening, it's kind of the top 10 links that you see on Google. So Google essentially tries to rank the top 10 websites. And it's crazy because there's tons of websites for a certain keyword, and Google only shows 10. But basically how it works is Google will rank you depending on how many other places link to you or other places are talking about you. And that's sort of like the basics. But then obviously the algorithm is so complex because it uses like links is the big one where let's say you have a website that's about a food blog. You can say, hey, go check out Kevin's delivery service if you want my food delivered to you. And then we would rank up for that delivery keyword. But in theory, how it works now is that Google's taking into account
从技术上讲，为了实现这一点，需要做些什么？是的。所以，SEO基本上，对于听众来说，就是你在谷歌上看到的排名前10的链接。谷歌本质上试图对前10个网站进行排名。这很疯狂，因为对于某个关键词有成千上万个网站，而谷歌只显示10个。但基本上它的工作原理是，谷歌会根据有多少其他地方链接到你，或者其他地方在谈论你，来对你进行排名。这算是基础。但显然算法非常复杂，因为它使用了链接作为主要因素。假设你有一个关于美食博客的网站，你可以说：“嘿，如果你想让我为你送餐，去看看凯文的送餐服务吧。”然后我们就会因为那个“送餐”关键词而排名上升。但从理论上讲，现在它的工作方式是谷歌会考虑
all the social shares too, right? Your Twitter mentions, because people aren't linking that much anymore because no one's really has blogs, right? You've probably seen, it's kind of like personal blogs have gone away and it's more about Twitter accounts, Medium accounts. Google is developing like what people call like ghost signals where it's like branded names. So like let's say your website's called like whatever, Kevin Store. If someone says, hey, Kevin Store is really great, Google will now sort of extract that sort of brand term and say, hey, someone's talking about this. Let's give it more weight into their algorithm about where to rank up. But that's sort of like how the algorithm works. And of course, one big part about this is making sure you have content on your website that talks about that service or product that you're selling. So if you're talking about food, your website should
所有的社交分享，对吧？你的推特提及，因为人们不再那么频繁地进行链接了，因为现在真的没几个人有博客了，对吧？你可能也注意到了，个人博客已经消失了，更多的是关于推特账号、Medium账号。谷歌正在开发人们所说的“幽灵信号”，也就是品牌名称。所以，假设你的网站叫什么“凯文商店”。如果有人说：“嘿，凯文商店真的很棒。”谷歌现在会提取这种品牌词，并说：“嘿，有人在谈论这个。”让我们在算法中给它更多的权重，决定它的排名位置。但这就是算法的工作方式。当然，这其中很重要的一部分是确保你的网站上有谈论你所销售的服务或产品的内容。所以如果你在谈论食物，你的网站应该
have content about food, food recipes, anything related to the space. That way Google can really index your website. Index just means like having Google sort of like having your site into their database and then maybe adding some categorizations of it. Like, hey, this website's about delivery and food and food recipes. So whenever we're thinking about search terms right to this sort of category, maybe let's try to rank this website and see if it should be a top 10 spot. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah, you really hit the nail on the head. I think having really good content and having the right sort of meta tags and getting the right social signals out there is super important.
有关于食物、食谱以及任何与该领域相关的内容。这样谷歌才能真正索引你的网站。“索引”只是意味着让谷歌把你的网站放入他们的数据库中，然后可能添加一些分类。比如：“嘿，这个网站是关于送餐、食物和食谱的。”所以每当我们想到与这类相关的搜索词时，也许我们可以尝试对这个网站进行排名，看看它是否应该进入前10名。是的，这很有道理。是的，你真的说到了点子上。我认为拥有非常好的内容、正确的元标签以及获得正确的社交信号是非常重要的。
Yeah, so you saw that Thumbtack was doing this really well. And even though, you know, Zarli might have a super slick product, they might be, let's say the 11th entry and Thumbtack is just killing it and they're getting all the top 10 entries. And so that made you realize just really how important marketing is.
是的，所以你看到Thumbtack在这方面做得非常好。即使Zarli可能有一个超级流畅的产品，他们可能只是第11个条目，而Thumbtack却做得风生水起，占据了所有前10名的位置。这让你意识到营销到底有多重要。
Yeah, that's exactly what it was. And I was just like, wow, this is crazy how, at least for me at the time, was like, oh, it's crazy how the marketing team is... We had people, I'm like, how come it's not half the company, right? That's for me because I'm like, we're not getting any customers. How come we're just like, no one cares about this, right? Yeah, I said there's an interesting story about, actually, the founder of Zappos, the shoe company, he actually died tragically from a suicide this year. But actually, the story about how he started Zappos is really inspiring. He literally just started it with sales. So you'd go on Zappos.com. He had a website that he built himself in just pure HTML. And when you bought a shoe, he would actually literally walk over to Payless, buy the shoe, and then mail it to you. That was his entire business. And so people look at that and they say, well, he did nothing. But no,
是的，确实就是这样。我当时就想，哇，这太疯狂了，至少对我当时来说，我想的是，营销团队怎么……我们有人，我心想，为什么营销人员不是公司的一半呢？对我来说是这样，因为我想，我们没有获得任何客户。为什么我们就像是……没人关心这个，对吧？是的，我说过有一个关于Zappos创始人（那家鞋类公司）的有趣故事，他今年不幸自杀了。但实际上，关于他如何创立Zappos的故事非常鼓舞人心。他真的是从销售开始的。你会去Zappos.com，他有一个自己用纯HTML构建的网站。当你买一双鞋时，他实际上会步行去Payless买下那双鞋，然后邮寄给你。这就是他的全部业务。所以人们看着那个说，好吧，他什么都没做。但不是，
he did all the sales and the marketing so that when you went to look for shoes online, you found Zappos first. And it turned out that was actually more important than warehousing or handling dropshipping or anything. Like once he had the right marketing, he could just go to the store, buy the shoe and then mail it to you. Yeah, exactly. And that's why I think marketing is so important now
他做了所有的销售和营销，所以当你上网找鞋子时，你先找到了Zappos。事实证明，这实际上比仓储或处理代发货等任何事情都更重要。一旦他有了正确的营销，他就可以直接去商店买鞋，然后邮寄给你。是的，完全正确。这就是为什么我认为营销现在如此重要
for people to, and really what marketing is kind of like a research of saying, hey, can you market this product? And with marketing, at least with SEO, this is the great thing about SEO. And I think people should always be thinking about SEO when starting any brand is because Google will literally tell you the search volume of a product or keyword that people could be searching for. So if someone's searching for a product, you know that there's demand and that you know that you can sell them something. And now you just need to show up first, but at least you know that there's some desire to buy the product. Where I think, at least for me,
对人们来说，真正的营销有点像是一种研究，即“嘿，你能推销这个产品吗？”通过营销，至少通过SEO，这是SEO最棒的地方。我认为人们在创立任何品牌时都应该考虑SEO，因为谷歌会直接告诉你人们可能搜索的产品或关键词的搜索量。所以如果有人在搜索某个产品，你就知道有需求，并且你知道你可以卖给他们东西。现在你只需要排在第一位，但至少你知道有购买该产品的欲望。而在我看来，至少对我来说，
one of the mistakes I made when I was first programming was I would just come up with ideas myself and be like, oh, this is a great idea, but nobody wanted it. So that made marketing even harder, right? Yeah. It's a really, really good call. I did the same thing. I made a hockey game when I was in college. And, you know, growing up in Canada, I loved hockey. But I wanted a sort of really kind of like extreme hockey game. There was like skeletons in it and landmines and it was crazy. And I thought it was actually pretty fun. And actually, I think it did have actually a good premise. But where it failed is was in all the details. It's like,
我刚开始编程时犯的一个错误是，我只会自己想出点子，然后觉得：“哦，这是一个很棒的点子。”但没人想要它。这让营销变得更加困难，对吧？是的。这是一个非常非常好的观点。我也做过同样的事情。我在大学时做过一个曲棍球游戏。你知道，在加拿大长大，我热爱曲棍球。但我想要一种非常极端的曲棍球游戏。里面有骷髅、地雷，非常疯狂。我觉得它其实挺好玩的。而且实际上，我认为它确实有一个很好的前提。但它失败的地方在于所有的细节。就像，
I didn't really know just broadly what people wanted to get out of a video game. And so yeah, knowing your audiences is super, super important. And even if you might have the right sort of overall vision, you still need to know your audience to get all those details right. Yeah. It's so important because once you sort of get that right, you know kind of how to market your product, you know what they want to buy. And I think too, I want to tell people is just like making something unique and custom, you always make a ton more money. For example, like Airbnb, right? That's an idea that people are like, why would I ever let a stranger into my home? But if you really look at the story of Airbnb, and I think people should study those, is the founders struggle for years because you're basically making a market. You're sort of trying to generate demand. And for those type of companies,
我并不真正知道人们从电子游戏中想要得到什么。所以，了解你的受众是非常非常重要的。即使你可能有正确的整体愿景，你仍然需要了解你的受众才能把所有细节做好。是的。这太重要了，因为一旦你做对了，你就知道如何推销你的产品，你知道他们想买什么。而且我也想告诉人们，制作独特和定制的东西，你总是能赚更多的钱。例如，Airbnb，对吧？这是一个人们会问“我为什么要让陌生人进我的家？”的点子。但如果你真的研究Airbnb的故事，我认为人们应该研究这些，创始人奋斗了多年，因为你基本上是在创造一个市场。你是在试图产生需求。对于这类公司，
it depends on where you are in your stage of life or what you want to do. You need to raise funding because you need to educate the market. And when you need to educate the market, that's always more expensive. So now when you think about Airbnb competitors, they're like, oh, hey, look, they can piggyback on Airbnb's market demand and desire that they've already created. So it's easier for them to go start a company versus before it was a crazy idea to start something like Airbnb. And they got very lucky that they made it. Kind of like Peter Thiel says, that's when you can kind of essentially make your own monopoly because they just created the market, they created the demand and they, Airbnb is now like a verb, right? Yeah, that's right.
这取决于你处于人生的哪个阶段，或者你想做什么。你需要筹集资金，因为你需要教育市场。当你需要教育市场时，这总是更昂贵的。所以现在当你想到Airbnb的竞争对手时，他们会说：“哦，嘿，看，他们可以搭上Airbnb已经创造的市场需求和欲望的顺风车。”所以他们去创业比以前容易多了，以前创办像Airbnb这样的公司是一个疯狂的想法。他们非常幸运才成功了。就像彼得·蒂尔所说，那是你可以基本上建立自己的垄断地位的时候，因为他们刚刚创造了市场，创造了需求，而Airbnb现在就像一个动词，对吧？是的，没错。
I mean, also, I mean, the iPad comes to mind. I remember when the iPad came out, there were all these memes, like someone took nine iPhones in a grid and they duct taped them together and they're like, I have my own iPad, you know? And now it's kind of obvious. It's like, especially for kids and for people who don't have laptops, you know, who don't want that kind of, who need something sort of ultra portable. It's a no brainer now to get an iPad, but yeah, Apple really made that market. Yeah. And I think what you said is so important. Like when it's obvious, that's when like, you know, you've made it like, oh, Airbnb is so obvious. iPads are so obvious. And that's like, as a marketer, that's like the dream, right? made it like oh airbnb is so obvious ipads are so obvious and that's like as a marketer that's like the dream right oh when it's so obvious because it wasn't
我的意思是，还有，iPad也浮现在脑海中。我记得iPad刚出来的时候，有很多模因，比如有人把九部iPhone排成网格，用胶带粘在一起，然后说：“我有我自己的iPad了，你知道吗？”现在这很明显了。尤其是对孩子和没有笔记本电脑的人来说，你知道，那些不需要那种……需要某种超便携设备的人。现在买iPad是不用动脑子的事，但确实，苹果真的创造了那个市场。是的，我认为你所说的是如此重要。当它变得显而易见时，那就是你知道你已经成功了的时候，比如“哦，Airbnb太明显了，iPad太明显了。”作为一名营销人员，那是梦想，对吧？当它如此明显时，因为在三年前它并不
obvious three years ago right yeah yeah totally so yeah so so at what point did you say like did you become a marketer at at zarly or or at some point you just said no i want to go into marketing and did you leave zarly at that point like how did that story unfold? Yeah. So at this time, I didn't think I was going to be a marketer, but what I wanted to do was I still wanted to do my own company. So I was still competing in stuff while at Zarly, like hackathons. I was competing in Startup Weekend San Francisco. I was at the team there and we won first place and then we went to qualcomm ventures to pitch them our product it was a great trip like we went to san diego for free pretty much we didn't win like the whatever half a million but yeah that was a great experience though so that sounds
明显，对吧？是的，完全正确。所以，你在什么时候说……你是在Zarly成为营销人员的，还是在某个时候你只是说“不，我想进入营销领域”，然后你在那个时候离开了Zarly？那个故事是怎么展开的？是的。当时，我没想过我会成为一名营销人员，但我想要做的是，我仍然想做我自己的公司。所以我还在Zarly工作时参加各种比赛，比如黑客马拉松。我参加了旧金山创业周末，我是那里的团队成员，我们赢得了第一名，然后我们去高通创投向他们推销我们的产品。那是一次很棒的旅行，我们几乎免费去了圣地亚哥。我们没有赢得那什么五十万，但是的，那确实是一次很棒的经历。所以这听起来
awesome yeah it was so fun i was like oh first time in san diego i was like oh like this is an awesome place i want to live here that's like i want to live here yes it is beautiful they have um yeah lego land is there so we go go there for Legoland and it's great. I was like, oh, this is awesome. I want to live here. And we didn't win. But by this time, I was like, I was like trying to still try to do my own startups and stuff. And then I was like, oh, at this time I was at Zorley for about three years now. And then I was like, oh, I want to come back to New York. And basically I left Zorley. I came back to New York. I was living at home with my mom because I was like, I didn't know where I wanted to live yet. And this is when the idea to start Maid Sailors came, which is the cleaning company. And the reason why I started the cleaning company was because similar to when I was at Zarly, the businesses that I was doing really well on the Zarly platform at the time were the home cleaning companies. But the issue that we were running when we were running the company, when I was working at Zarly, was that the maids could only take so many jobs at a time before
很棒。是的，太有趣了。我当时想：“哦，第一次去圣地亚哥，我心想，哦，这是一个很棒的地方，我想住在这里。”就是那种“我想住在这里”的感觉。是的，它很美。他们有……是的，乐高乐园在那里，所以我们去那里玩乐高乐园，很棒。我当时想：“哦，这太棒了，我想住在这里。”我们没赢。但到这个时候，我还在尝试做我自己的初创公司之类的。然后我心想，哦，当时我在Zarly已经待了大约三年了。然后我心想，哦，我想回纽约。基本上我离开了Zarly。我回到了纽约。我和我妈妈住在一起，因为我不知道我想住在哪里。就在这时，创办Maid Sailors的想法出现了，那是一家清洁公司。我创办清洁公司的原因是因为，类似于我在Zarly的时候，当时在Zarly平台上做得很好的业务是家庭清洁公司。但我们在经营公司时遇到的问题，当我在Zarly工作时，是清洁工一次只能接那么多工作，直到
they were booked up. And usually the best maids were booked up and say, hey guys, the platform's great. I just can't take any more cleanings because essentially it's recurring now, right? People just want the cleanings with the same person all the time. Oh yeah. You kind of work yourself out of business in terms know, in terms of Zarly, they do such a good job that people don't need them anymore. Exactly. So then for me, my idea was this. What if I make like an Uber for cleaners
他们被订满了。通常最好的清洁工都被订满了，他们会说：“嘿，伙计们，平台很棒。我只是不能再接清洁工作了，因为本质上现在是循环的，对吧？”人们总是想要同一个人进行清洁。哦，是的。你实际上是在让自己失业，就Zarly而言，他们做得太好了，以至于人们不再需要他们了。完全正确。所以对我来说，我的想法是这样的：如果我做一个像Uber一样的清洁服务，
where like they hire me, the company, and then I'm finding these sort of like cleaners to come in and I'll rotate people back and forth. That way, basically, that's literally what's called like Uber for cleaning. That's literally what my tagline was. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah, I think because the people too, that's good for them because they don't have to deal with, oh, you know, my cleaner moved and now I have to find another cleaner.
他们雇佣我，公司，然后我找到这些清洁工来，我会轮换人员。这样，基本上，这字面上就是所谓的“清洁界的Uber”。这字面上就是我的标语。是的，这很有道理。是的，我认为因为人们也是，这对他们来说很好，因为他们不必处理“哦，你知道，我的清洁工搬走了，现在我必须找另一个清洁工。”
So you kind of take care of all of that, let's say, risk, for lack of a better word, and in exchange, you're able to provide kind of more value. It's exactly what you said. It's like, basically, we as a company now take the risk of, hey, did they show up on time? Did they clean properly? The refunds, right? All this stuff that could potentially go wrong with the cleaning. We as a company now say, hey, look, we'll guarantee this for you. And a big thing that I wanted to do at that time, which is kind of obvious now, was that we put our pricing online. So basically we have like what we call flat rate pricing, where I say, you have a studio, it's going to be like 110. You have a one bedroom, it's going to be 130. Where previous before how cleaning companies work,
所以你基本上承担了所有这些，怎么说呢，风险，为了缺乏更好的词，作为交换，你能够提供更多的价值。这正是你所说的。就像，基本上，我们作为一家公司现在承担了风险，比如：“嘿，他们准时到了吗？他们打扫干净了吗？退款，对吧？”所有这些可能在清洁过程中出错的事情。我们作为一家公司现在说：“嘿，看，我们会为你保证这一点。”我当时想做的一件大事，现在看来很明显，就是我们把价格放在了网上。所以基本上我们有我们所谓的统一费率定价，我说：“你有一个单间公寓，大概是110。你有一个一居室，大概是130。”而以前清洁公司的工作方式，
like let's say Molly Maids or maids.com was that you would call them and then they would send some sort of rep to your home and say, hey, based on your size, this is how much it's going to be. And in theory, it's great because A, you charge the true price that it might cost. But B, it's also, if it's too expensive, you just wasted someone's time and you wasted the company's time about essentially getting a lead that didn't close. So for us, it's like, we didn't want to do this sort of like back and forth to the clients, like you're there. It's like this awkward conversation.
比如Molly Maids或maids.com，是你打电话给他们，然后他们会派某种代表到你家说：“嘿，根据你的面积，价格会是这样。”从理论上讲，这很好，因为A，你收取了它可能花费的真实价格。但B，如果太贵了，你也浪费了别人的时间，也浪费了公司的时间，基本上是获得了一个没有成交的潜在客户。所以对我们来说，我们不想和客户进行这种来回的沟通，就像你在那里一样。这就像这种尴尬的对话。
It's like, hey, I want to price it like SaaS companies at a time where SaaS companies now hide pricing, right? Because it's like, hey, put a demo with us, right? Where back then everybody had their pricing online. Yep. Yep. Well, yeah, I think SaaS is interesting. If you look at like the actual cloud stuff, there's like a race to the bottom.
就像，“嘿，我想像当时的SaaS公司那样定价，SaaS公司现在隐藏价格，对吧？”因为就像，“嘿，和我们预约演示，对吧？”而当时每个人都在网上公布他们的价格。是的。是的。好吧，是的，我认为SaaS很有趣。如果你看看实际的云服务，那是一场逐底竞争。
But then when you look at the people who are in the middle, yeah, they're charging like unbelievable amounts. And sometimes it ramps up exponentially. So it's fine in the beginning and then you get here with a huge bill. Yep. Asana is like that too. We use Asana here and it's like, okay, it's great. We just little upgrade it.
但当你看看那些处于中间的人，是的，他们收取令人难以置信的金额。有时它呈指数级增长。所以开始时还可以，然后你就会收到一张巨额账单。是的。Asana也是这样。我们在这里使用Asana，它就像，好吧，它很棒。我们只是稍微升级了一下。
And they're like, you need to buy 10 seats at once. And I'm like, I just need one more seat. They're like, no, you're above the plan. I'm like, this makes no sense. So anyways, that's how I started the cleaning company. And that was my unique way of cleaning. Hey, let's just put our pricing online and then you can book online. And this is, for made sellers, this is where I truly learned how to do more marketing. Because at this time, I quit my job and I was like, I want to make this
然后他们说：“你需要一次购买10个席位。”我心想：“我只需要再多一个席位。”他们说：“不，你超过了计划。”我心想：“这毫无意义。”所以无论如何，这就是我创办清洁公司的方式。这就是我独特的清洁方式。嘿，让我们把价格放在网上，然后你可以在线预订。对于Maid Sailors来说，这是我真正学会如何做更多营销的地方。因为在这个时候，我辞职了，我想：“我想让这家
company successful. I want to go all in on marketing. And that's when I started reading books, SEO. I started learning how to rank stuff. I started learning about Google My Businesses. And really for me, when I started SEO and sort of marketing, I wanted to see how are people making money online through some sort of like cutthroat industry. So I was looking into like how affiliate marketers were ranking their stuff because these guys are taking like a small cut of a cut. So then I was like looking at what these guys were doing and sort of kind of reverse engineering their tactics. Yeah, that makes sense. And also, as you said, by starting that, there are all maids.com, there's a lot of companies out there. And so the way you differentiated yourself with your pricing
公司成功。我想全力投入营销。”那时我开始阅读书籍，SEO。我开始学习如何对东西进行排名。我开始学习关于Google My Business。对我来说，当我开始SEO和营销时，我想看看人们是如何通过某种残酷的行业在线赚钱的。所以我研究了联盟营销人员是如何对他们的东西进行排名的，因为这些人只是从分成中拿一小部分。所以我研究了这些人正在做什么，并对他们的策略进行了逆向工程。是的，这很有道理。而且，正如你所说，通过开始那个，有所有的maids.com，外面有很多公司。所以你用你的定价来区分自己的方式
model, that needed to get out there. Like people need to see that, oh, I don't have to call this company and let them do an inspection and take a day off work. And then, oh, the price is too expensive. Like they needed to know that your alternative existed. And so you needed to get that word out there. And especially in the beginning, get that word out there in like a cost effective way,
模型，那需要传播出去。人们需要看到，“哦，我不必打电话给这家公司，让他们进行检查，还要请一天假。然后，哦，价格太贵了。”他们需要知道你的替代方案存在。所以你需要把那个消息传出去。特别是在开始的时候，以一种具有成本效益的方式把那个消息传出去，
or at least measure the ROI and everything. So I think that's a really good way to really dive into the deep end on marketing. Yeah. And that was a big thing for us. It's like, Hey, come to us because remember, like we didn't want to waste time. We want to, and the reason too, with marketing is we want to be able to track the conversion directly and then say, Hey, was this effective? So if someone could book directly online, then you know, it works. It's kind of like, you like now if someone says, call to book, it's like, okay, what's the sales cycle? You have to hold, you have to CRM, you have to track them. Okay, what's the sort of process? It's so complicated. Digital marketing has made it so easy where you can make it so someone can
或者至少衡量投资回报率等等。所以我认为这是一个真正深入营销领域的好方法。是的，这对我们来说是一件大事。就像，“嘿，来找我们，因为记住，我们不想浪费时间。我们想要，而且营销的原因也是我们想要能够直接跟踪转化，然后说，嘿，这有效吗？”所以如果有人可以直接在线预订，那么你就知道它有效。这就像，你现在如果有人说“打电话预订”，就像，“好吧，销售周期是什么？你必须保持，你必须有CRM，你必须跟踪他们。好吧，流程是什么？”这太复杂了。数字营销让它变得如此简单，你可以让某人
literally give you their credit card right now. You can say, yep, this thing was profitable or not profitable. Yeah. Did you use any software to help you with all of that? Like Salesforce comes to mind or SugarCRM or these things. A lot of them now have some forecasting built in where they'll kind of replay what happened and they'll give you advice. Like maybe you should have emailed this person more or things like that. Have you looked into any of this? And even through to today, have you looked into a lot of the sort of automated marketing or ML marketing? What's kind of your take on that? Yeah. So basically in the beginning for made sellers, I wanted to do like my own custom
字面上现在就给你他们的信用卡。你可以说，“是的，这东西是有利可图的还是无利可图的。”是的。你用了什么软件来帮助你处理所有这些吗？比如Salesforce浮现在脑海中，或者SugarCRM或这些东西。它们现在很多都有内置的预测功能，它们会重播发生的事情，并给你建议。比如“也许你应该多给这个人发邮件”之类的事情。你研究过这些吗？甚至直到今天，你研究过很多那种自动化营销或机器学习营销吗？你对此有什么看法？是的。所以基本上在Maid Sailors的开始阶段，我想做我自己的定制
website, like Zany Developer, right? Where it's like, hey, I can make my own custom CRM. I can make my own custom checkout. I was like, I know Stripe. I know APIs. I know how to track all this stuff, right? So I was like, I'm not going to I know APIs. I know how to track all this stuff, right? So I was like, I'm not going to use WordPress. WordPress sucks, right? So that's really like what... So basically in the beginning, I built it all. And then when I was basically doing marketing, I was like, okay, I need to create landing pages. And I was just like, oh, okay, now I got to go into my code editor. I got to go deploy it back to GitHub. I got to push it to Heroku. I was like, I just want to make a simple text change. And then that's where I was like, okay, I can see why marketers
网站，像Zany Developer，对吧？就像，“嘿，我可以制作我自己的定制CRM。我可以制作我自己的定制结账。”我心想：“我知道Stripe。我知道API。我知道如何跟踪所有这些东西，对吧？”所以我心想：“我不会使用WordPress。WordPress很烂，对吧？”所以这真的是……所以基本上在开始的时候，我构建了所有东西。然后当我基本上在做营销时，我心想：“好吧，我需要创建着陆页。”我当时就想：“哦，好吧，现在我得进入我的代码编辑器。我得把它部署回GitHub。我得把它推送到Heroku。”我心想：“我只是想做一个简单的文本修改。”然后就在那时，我心想：“好吧，我能看出为什么营销人员
now get pissed off at developers because they don't want to do the simple stuff because it's like tedious, but it's so necessary for marketing to maybe change the headline, change the image, because you want to see if this is going to give you a different result. And pretty much after a few months, I was like, okay, I don't want to be doing the coding. I really want to be doing the marketing and I want to be doing all the tests. And then that's when I reconverted the website into WordPress with like a custom theme. And then that's when I started using the software platform called Launch27 that allowed us to take bookings online, but at the same time, manage all the cleaners, manage all the customers and emails.
现在对开发人员感到恼火，因为他们不想做简单的事情，因为这很乏味，但对于营销来说，修改标题、修改图片是非常必要的，因为你想看看这是否会给你带来不同的结果。几个月后，我心想：“好吧，我不想做编码了。我真的想做营销，我想做所有的测试。”然后就在那时，我用一个定制主题将网站重新转换成了WordPress。然后就在那时，我开始使用名为Launch27的软件平台，它允许我们在网上接受预订，但同时管理所有的清洁工、管理所有的客户和电子邮件。
And really at that point, I was just completely focused on bringing in new customers, changing the marketing and messaging and the language of the website. And Launch27 is sort of like that CRM that you're saying that gives us all these analytics of how much revenue you're bringing, how much customers you're bringing, who's booking, maybe what are some of the best upsells, et cetera. So yeah, I haven't heard of that one. Is Launch27, so just a bit of background for people. So CMS is Customer Management System. And the difference between a CMS and like a database
真的在那个时候，我完全专注于引入新客户，改变营销和信息以及网站的语言。Launch27就像你所说的那个CRM，它为我们提供了所有这些分析，关于你带来了多少收入，你带来了多少客户，谁在预订，也许什么是最好的追加销售，等等。所以是的，我没听说过那个。Launch27是，所以给人们一点背景知识。所以CMS是客户管理系统。CMS和数据库之间的区别
is that you have some business logic. You know, at the simplest, you have more advanced fields like zip code, which, you know, if you put in someone's zip code and you want to get back their city, if you just use a regular database, you have to do that by hand. A CRM could have some logic. It could know about the relationship between zip codes and cities. And so you can imagine a whole bunch of other business logic, especially around pricing, maybe in taxes. And so it really helps you a lot more than just using MongoDB or something. But traditionally CMS is where these
在于你有一些业务逻辑。你知道，最简单地说，你有更高级的字段，比如邮政编码，你知道，如果你输入某人的邮政编码，你想取回他们的城市，如果你只使用常规数据库，你必须手动完成。CRM可以有一些逻辑。它可以知道邮政编码和城市之间的关系。所以你可以想象还有一大堆其他的业务逻辑，特别是在定价方面，也许还有税收。所以它确实比只使用MongoDB之类的东西对你有更多的帮助。但传统上，CMS是这些
monolithic things where the CMS would have its own website. And so you would go into the CMS website and put in all this information. And then if you wanted to show that information on your own website, they would provide some kind of API. It usually wasn't very good because that wasn't their real business. So then what ended up happening was people started coming up with these things called headless CMS. And a headless CMS is one where they say, we're not going to do a front end at all. And we're just going to focus 100% on writing the cleanest, nicest API. And so we're going to let you take this customer data and render it or put it on a phone or do whatever you want. And so that's become a big thing
单体的东西，CMS会有它自己的网站。所以你会进入CMS网站并输入所有这些信息。然后如果你想在自己的网站上显示这些信息，他们会提供某种API。它通常不是很好，因为那不是他们的真正业务。所以后来发生的事情是，人们开始想出这些被称为“无头CMS”的东西。无头CMS是指他们说：“我们根本不做前端。我们只专注于编写最干净、最好的API。”所以我们将让你获取这些客户数据并渲染它，或者把它放在手机上，或者做任何你想做的事情。所以这已经成为一件大事
nowadays. And so is Launch27 like a headless CMS or what category does it fall into? Yeah, it's essentially like a headless CMS thing where basically, yeah, it's exactly what you said. It's kind of like a database with just like more advanced logic. It'll tell you like, you know, your customers, how many times they're booking, who's your best customer, you know, where they live, are they in your service area? We use it all for almost everything. It allows us to charge people, to refund people. And yeah, Launch has really developed for services businesses. And the founders started their own cleaning company. So he basically built it out of a need, which is great because he knew all the pain points. And CMS or some sort of CRM system,
现在。所以Launch27是像无头CMS吗，还是它属于什么类别？是的，它本质上就像一个无头CMS的东西，基本上，是的，它正是你所说的。它有点像一个带有更高级逻辑的数据库。它会告诉你，你知道，你的客户，他们预订了多少次，谁是你最好的客户，你知道，他们住在哪里，他们在你的服务区域内吗？我们几乎把所有东西都用它。它允许我们向人们收费，给人们退款。而且是的，Launch确实是为服务型企业开发的。创始人创办了他自己的清洁公司。所以他基本上是出于需要构建了它，这很棒，因为他知道所有的痛点。CMS或某种CRM系统，
I think is so key to a lot of businesses just so you can have all this data. And then you could use it later on to see like how to upsell, how to downsell, how to market better. So yeah, I think that's exactly what Launch27 is. Cool. It makes sense. And so, yeah, I mean, I'm sure every developer has the same story where, you know, you come out saying, oh, this has 99% of what I need. I'm going to write it from scratch. And that is super, super fulfilling. And I don't discourage people from doing that at all. But as soon as you go into maintenance mode, that's when you realize like, oh, as cool as it was to build that,
我认为对很多企业来说是如此关键，这样你就可以拥有所有这些数据。然后你以后可以用它来看看如何追加销售，如何降级销售，如何更好地营销。所以是的，我认为Launch27就是那样。酷。这很有道理。所以，是的，我的意思是，我相信每个开发人员都有同样的故事，你知道，你出来说：“哦，这有我需要的99%。我要从头开始写它。”这超级超级有成就感。我一点也不劝阻人们这样做。但一旦你进入维护模式，那就是你意识到的时候，比如：“哦，构建它虽然很酷，
it's not really cool anymore. And now I'm still spending a bunch of time on it. I was actually thinking the other day about what to do with our blog. We're on, we're on blogger and yeah. And it's, it's, it's tough because building it yourself really opens up a lot of doors, but the maintenance is, is a big issue. So the, you have the, um, the site up and running, you have, you know, really solid marketing, you have WordPress, um, you have this launch 27. And so my guess is on the marketing side, uh, on side, on the outbound side, let's say you're doing Facebook ads, Google ads, SEO, emails probably, like you have email lists. Can you kind of walk us through what your marketing kind of looks like nowadays?
但它不再那么酷了。现在我还在上面花了一大堆时间。”我前几天还在想我们的博客该怎么办。我们在Blogger上，是的。而且，这很难，因为自己构建它确实打开了很多大门，但维护是一个大问题。所以，你让网站上线并运行，你有，你知道，非常扎实的营销，你有WordPress，你有这个Launch27。所以我的猜测是，在营销方面，在出站方面，假设你在做Facebook广告、谷歌广告、SEO，电子邮件可能，比如你有电子邮件列表。你能带我们了解一下你现在的营销看起来是什么样的吗？
Yeah. So marketing for local businesses is, I think, so great because at least something like Google has made it really easy for local businesses to get in front of people. So when I was first starting, Google Maps, you guys, obviously everybody knows Google Maps, but you know how now there's those listings of businesses? Yeah. When I was doing the made company, those just came out. So that was a crazy boost for us in traffic and sort of calls that we were getting. So we were optimizing to be basically number one there. Is that sponsored? I don't actually know where that data comes from. So Google just added the sponsored stuff maybe a year ago, but for almost a few, two, three years, it was great for people like us where it was free
是的。所以本地企业的营销，我认为太棒了，因为至少像谷歌这样的东西已经让本地企业很容易出现在人们面前。所以当我刚开始的时候，谷歌地图，你们，显然每个人都知道谷歌地图，但你知道现在那些企业列表吗？是的。当我做清洁公司时，那些刚刚出来。所以这对我们的流量和我们接到的电话来说是一个疯狂的推动。所以我们正在优化，基本上在那里排名第一。那是赞助的吗？我其实不知道那些数据来自哪里。所以谷歌可能在一年前才添加了赞助的东西，但几乎有两、三年，这对我们这样的人来说很棒，它是免费的
or quote unquote free, right? Where basically Google would just give you the one or two spots for free. But now it's sponsored. But now instead of seeing three, you'll see five, but I think two are sponsored. Oh, I see. And the other three come from, do you ask Google to put you on the list or are they just scanning businesses? How does that work? Yeah. So you basically just confirm with Google that you're a real business. So they have this thing called Google My Business where you apply and then they make you upload like your business license, your phone number. They'll call you.
或者所谓的免费，对吧？基本上谷歌会免费给你那一两个位置。但现在它是赞助的。但现在你看到的不是三个，你会看到五个，但我认为有两个是赞助的。哦，我明白了。另外三个来自，你要求谷歌把你列入名单，还是他们只是在扫描企业？那是怎么运作的？是的。所以你基本上只是向谷歌确认你是一家真正的企业。所以他们有这个叫Google My Business的东西，你申请，然后他们让你上传像你的营业执照、你的电话号码。他们会给你打电话。
The program is really designed to get local businesses traffic, right? So they want to make sure that you're legit. And the reason why is because there's a lot of companies, obviously, you know, with any sort of business out there, there's people that basically made fake listings in order to just control the market. Yeah. Yeah. Totally makes sense. Cool. So my business, so that was, I think, a big part of it. A big part of it. And then also another big one for us, it was Yelp.
这个程序确实是为了给本地企业带来流量，对吧？所以他们想确保你是合法的。原因是因为有很多公司，显然，你知道，对于任何类型的企业，都有人基本上制造了虚假列表，只是为了控制市场。是的。是的。完全有道理。酷。所以我的业务，所以那是我认为很大的一部分。很大的一部分。然后还有另一个对我们来说很大的，是Yelp。
People use Yelp here in New York City a lot. And so basically for any business, the way we thought about it was trying to think about where your customer is potentially going to find you, right? So for right now, if you're like a local food company, you probably need to be on Seamless. You probably need to be on Uber Eats. You probably need to be on DoorDash because now these are just sources of traffic for your business. And you need to be on there because they just have so much users that probably want food and you need to at least show up somehow, right? I think sometimes businesses make mistakes where it's like, kind of what you said before, like, Hey, people will just find me.
人们在纽约市经常使用Yelp。所以基本上对于任何企业，我们考虑它的方式是试图考虑你的客户可能在哪里找到你，对吧？所以现在，如果你是一家本地食品公司，你可能需要出现在Seamless上。你可能需要出现在Uber Eats上。你可能需要出现在DoorDash上，因为现在这些只是你业务的流量来源。而且你需要出现在那里，因为他们有太多的用户可能想要食物，你需要至少以某种方式出现，对吧？我认为有时企业会犯错误，就像你之前说的，比如：“嘿，人们会找到我的。”
I'm like, that's not how things work. That's not how things work. Yeah, totally. So you mentioned a lot of different things. There's Yelp, there's Google, there's, there's my business, there's a different part of Google. Like, how do you, as this is getting a bit more in the technical side, how do you as a developer or, you know or a marketer, maybe if it's a smaller company and you're the marketer is also doing some development, how do you talk to all of these different systems? Is there a middle layer that you use or is it really just going through looking at the My Business API, looking at the Yelp API and just doing it one at a time? Yeah, that's essentially what it is. There there's some services out there
我心想：“事情不是那样运作的。”事情不是那样运作的。是的，完全正确。所以你提到了很多不同的东西。有Yelp，有谷歌，有我的业务，有谷歌的不同部分。那么，作为这变得更技术化的一面，你作为开发人员，或者，你知道，或者营销人员，也许如果是一家较小的公司，而你是营销人员同时也在做一些开发，你如何与所有这些不同的系统对话？有一个你使用的中间层吗，还是它真的只是通过查看My Business API，查看Yelp API，然后一个一个地做？是的，本质上就是这样。外面有一些服务
that are trying to make it all like into one, especially because there's Yelp reviews, there's Google reviews, and you have to like basically manage all these platforms. So now there's APIs getting built around a central like database or some sort of central platform where you can like talk to people on here. But yeah, for right now, how we do it is
试图把它们全部变成一个，特别是因为有Yelp评论，有谷歌评论，你必须基本上管理所有这些平台。所以现在有API围绕一个中央数据库或某种中央平台构建，你可以在这里和人们交谈。但是的，目前，我们这样做的方式是
we just have people just log into these accounts one by one and respond to people one by one. It's just like manual work. And that's what we've seen the best. But even with Yelp, for example, Yelp doesn't like, Yelp will notify you of, let's say a new request. So we have like a Zapier that will ping our Slack that says, hey, look, someone on Yelp sent you a message, log in now to check in and respond. Oh, that's a really good that says, hey, look, someone on Yelp sent you a message. Log in now to check in and respond. Oh, that's a really good idea. So yeah, let me cover that real quick. So Zapier is this awesome product.
我们只是让人一个一个地登录这些账户，一个一个地回复人们。这就像体力活。这就是我们看到的最好的方式。但即使是Yelp，例如，Yelp不喜欢，Yelp会通知你，比如一个新的请求。所以我们有像Zapier这样的东西，会ping我们的Slack，说：“嘿，看，Yelp上有人给你发了消息，现在登录去查看并回复。”哦，那是一个非常好的，说：“嘿，看，Yelp上有人给你发了消息。现在登录去查看并回复。”哦，那是一个非常好的主意。所以，是的，让我快速介绍一下。所以Zapier是这个很棒的产品。
Actually, we should definitely do a show on Zapier in the future, but there's other ones that are starting to come up, but Zapier has really taken the market, at least for now. And the idea is, similar to what we were saying, you might want to do marketing, multi-channel marketing, but you don't want to be an expert on the Yelp API, the Google API, right? Or you could be a developer
实际上，我们将来绝对应该做一个关于Zapier的节目，但还有其他一些开始出现的，但Zapier确实占领了市场，至少目前是这样。这个想法是，类似于我们所说的，你可能想做营销，多渠道营销，但你不想成为Yelp API、谷歌API的专家，对吧？或者你可以成为一名开发人员
and have many different platforms you run on, like you could have Android, iOS, et cetera. And so what Zapier does is it basically allows you to pass messages and notifications between all these different systems in a WYSIWYG kind of way. So you could just say, and actually we have a Zapier for the show where when someone ats us on Twitter, Zapier goes and writes the tweet onto a channel in our Discord. Of course, now that I said that, we'll probably get, who knows what will happen, but it's a really cool feature where people can just go to this
并且有许多不同的平台运行，比如你可以有Android、iOS等等。所以Zapier所做的是，它基本上允许你以一种所见即所得的方式在所有这些不同的系统之间传递消息和通知。所以你可以只说，实际上我们为节目有一个Zapier，当有人在推特上@我们时，Zapier会去把推文写到我们Discord的一个频道里。当然，既然我说了这个，我们可能会得到，谁知道会发生什么，但这是一个非常酷的功能，人们可以去这个
channel on Discord and just see what folks are saying about the show. And it allows them to kind of like start threads and conversations. So yeah, Zapier is amazing. And so I think what you're saying, Kevin, is Zapier has connected your Yelp and your Slack so that you can get notified right away and you don't have to be monitoring two different things. Exactly. And like, yeah, Zapier is like awesome. Like we use it for like almost everything here for like the cleaning company or for like, let's say, Void Media when we're onboarding new clients, there's some sort of zap there. It's one of those companies that like, at least for me, I'm like,
Discord上的频道，看看人们在谈论节目什么。它允许他们有点像开始主题和对话。所以是的，Zapier太棒了。所以我认为你所说的是，凯文，Zapier连接了你的Yelp和你的Slack，这样你就可以立即得到通知，而不必监控两件不同的事情。完全正确。而且，是的，Zapier太棒了。就像我们在这里几乎把所有东西都用它，比如清洁公司，或者比如Void Media，当我们入职新客户时，那里有某种Zap。它是那种公司，至少对我来说，我心想：
why didn't I build this, right? Why didn't I build this? Yeah, I know. Well, probably, you know, the challenge, like you said, not only building it, but you have to market it. It's like, how do you market?
“为什么我没构建这个，对吧？为什么我没构建这个？”是的，我知道。好吧，可能，你知道，挑战，就像你说的，不仅是构建它，你还必须推销它。就像，你如何推销？
Like, I don't even know what the market is. I mean, obviously it's software developers, but like within software developers, I don't really know like how I would market Zapier. I mean, you'd probably be a good person to answer that one. Zapier probably, I've studied Zapier's marketing. They have the best SEO strategy of like ever seen. They have millions of organic visitors a month and their marketing strategy is this. So let's obviously we're using Zencaster, right? So let's say you also have like Anchor to like, you know, whatever to host your podcast. They have a page called Zapier Zencaster to Anchor.
就像，我甚至不知道市场是什么。我的意思是，显然它是软件开发人员，但就像在软件开发人员内部，我真的不知道我将如何推销Zapier。我的意思是，你可能是一个回答那个问题的好人。Zapier可能，我研究过Zapier的营销。他们有我见过的最好的SEO策略。他们每个月有数百万的有机访问者，他们的营销策略是这样的：所以让我们显然我们正在使用Zencaster，对吧？所以假设你也有像Anchor这样的，你知道，无论什么来托管你的播客。他们有一个页面叫“Zapier Zencaster to Anchor”。
And basically, they just generate all these variations of marketing tools, tools, software tools. And they have tons and tons of these SEO pages that people will search for. People probably search for how to integrate Zencast with Anchor. And Zapier probably ranks number one. Oh, my gosh. I mean you you really just opened it up completely because that's exactly what happened i looked up how do i send messages from twitter to discord and and it just happened yeah you're right so so they've
基本上，他们只是生成了所有这些营销工具、软件工具的变体。他们有海量的 SEO 页面供人们搜索。人们可能会搜索如何将 Zencast 与 Anchor 集成。而 Zapier 可能排名第一。天哪。我的意思是，你真的完全揭开了这个秘密，因为事实确实如此。我查过如何将推特消息发送到 Discord，结果就是这样。是的，你是对的，所以他们
gone through and done the n squared thing right of all the different things you can connect to them and they've built landing pages for all of them yep and their landing pages are like and i think too for people listening like their landing pages are really well thought out they have like reviews they have like the connections they have like sometimes they have like editorial comments of like why the software is good or bad right so they've done a really good job of like educating the user and this shows google like hey we should be number one yeah i mean this is a real i'm so glad we brought this up. I mean, this is such a good call out because Zapier from a tech standpoint, I mean, it's laborious to integrate all these things,
已经完成了所有这些你可以连接的各种事物的“n 平方”工作，并为它们都建立了落地页。是的，他们的落地页就像是……而且我认为对于听众来说，他们的落地页考虑得非常周到，有评论，有连接方式，有时还有关于为什么该软件好或坏的编辑评论，对吧？所以他们在教育用户方面做得非常好，这向谷歌展示了：嘿，我们应该排在第一位。是的，我的意思是，这是一个真正的……我很高兴我们提到了这一点。我的意思是，这是一个非常好的切入点，因为从技术角度来看，Zapier，我的意思是，集成所有这些东西是很费力的，
but it's, as you said, it's not hard. And so people might look at that and say, yeah, I could have built this when I was in high school and I'd have a multimillion dollar company. But no, it's like, it's the SEO and it's getting to the top of the list and everything. That is what separates Zapier from all the other people who have the same idea at the same time.
但正如你所说，这并不难。所以人们可能会看一眼说，是的，我高中时就能做出这个，然后我就能拥有一家价值数百万美元的公司了。但不是这样的，这是关于 SEO，是关于进入列表顶部等等。这正是 Zapier 与所有其他同时有同样想法的人的区别所在。
Yeah. Zapier is awesome. And yeah, there's a ton of competitors now, but it's going to be a while to take them down just because this organic flywheel that they built is just crazy. Yeah. So let's jump into that. So what is a flywheel and why do marketers keep talking about that? So basically, a flywheel is just a way to just generate traffic or generate
是的。Zapier 太棒了。而且是的，现在有很多竞争对手，但要打败他们还需要一段时间，仅仅因为他们建立的这种有机飞轮太疯狂了。是的。那么让我们深入探讨一下。什么是飞轮，为什么营销人员一直在谈论它？基本上，飞轮只是一种以可重复的方式产生流量或产生
customers in a repeatable fashion, right? So for example, if we're talking about Zapier, Zapier probably found out that, hey, if we're building these sort of like comparison pages, essentially, or integration pages, I think that's what they call them, integration pages. They basically said like, hey, and basically how it starts off with any business is you kind of have a hypothesis or a test, say, hey, let's make 10 of these, right? And that way, kind of what you said before too, it's like, this is a lot of work, right? It's developing all these pages, tons and tons of work. So you don't want to go and just like have a whole strategy of building this and you
客户的方法，对吧？所以，例如，如果我们谈论 Zapier，Zapier 可能发现，嘿，如果我们建立这些比较页面，或者本质上是集成页面，我想这就是他们所称的，集成页面。他们基本上说，嘿，而且基本上任何业务的开始都是你有一种假设或测试，说，嘿，让我们做 10 个这样的页面，对吧？这样，就像你之前说的，这需要很多工作，对吧？开发所有这些页面需要大量的工作。所以你不想直接制定一个完整的构建策略，而
don't know if it works. So basically, Zapier probably did. I think they did this because I was listening to one of their top marketers and he was kind of talking about this. They had this strategy or this theory, okay, if we make these integration pages and we can rank organically, will that increase the user signups or will that increase trials, you know, trials essentially. Right. And pretty much what they said after a few months of testing this, they saw that organic traffic was bringing them tons of qualified leads. And now they stay pretty much said, Hey, this, this sort of integration pages is working well. So then they basically now can,
你不知道它是否有效。所以基本上，Zapier 可能就是这么做的。我想他们是这样做的，因为我当时在听他们的一位顶级营销人员谈论这个。他们有这个策略或理论，好吧，如果我们制作这些集成页面，并且我们能够进行自然排名，这会增加用户注册量吗？或者这会增加试用量，你知道，本质上的试用。对。而且他们在测试几个月后几乎说，他们看到自然流量为他们带来了大量合格的潜在客户。现在他们基本上说，嘿，这种集成页面效果很好。所以他们现在基本上可以，
we said went to the database and basically looked at all the top integrations and started making integration pages. And then this basically generate this huge flywheel of organic traffic for people looking for these sort of integrations for their system and then that's sort of now where they're getting they said that they're getting most of their leads and free trials from organic now because this system has just worked well so well for them yeah so if another company has done this really well too is i think we mentioned them before, Airbnb. So Airbnb also has these travel pages that they are using now to rank above Expedia or all these Travelocity companies. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah. And imagine just all the different things that Zapier tried that
我们说去数据库里，基本上查看了所有顶级的集成，并开始制作集成页面。然后这基本上为那些寻找这些系统集成的人产生了巨大的自然流量飞轮，这就是他们现在说他们大部分潜在客户和免费试用都来自自然流量的原因，因为这个系统对他们来说效果太好了。是的，所以如果另一家公司也做得很好，我想我们之前提到过他们，Airbnb。所以 Airbnb 现在也使用这些旅游页面来在 Expedia 或所有这些 Travelocity 公司之上排名。是的，这很有道理。是的。想象一下 Zapier 尝试过的所有
didn't work, right? I mean, that's another thing that we don't really think about, but not only do you have to do good marketing, but you have to have the velocity to try a lot of things, to pivot a lot. You have to have that synergy between your marketers and your engineers, or if you're doing it all, you have to be able to build systems
没有成功的事情，对吧？我的意思是，这是我们不太考虑的另一件事，但你不仅需要做好营销，你还必须有尝试很多事情、频繁调整方向的速度。你必须在营销人员和工程师之间建立那种协同作用，或者如果你是一个人做，你必须能够构建系统
that can be flexible and that have that velocity. Because I'm sure they probably tried Facebook ads. They probably tried Google ads. Maybe they set up a My Business for SF, right? If they're an SF. And then they settled on that one thing that works. Yeah, exactly. And that's why, going back to marketing,
这些系统既灵活又具备那种速度。因为我敢肯定他们可能尝试过 Facebook 广告。他们可能尝试过谷歌广告。也许他们为旧金山设置了一个“我的商家”，对吧？如果他们在旧金山的话。然后他们最终确定了那个有效的方法。是的，完全正确。这就是为什么，回到营销，
sometimes what you read online or what you see from these companies, they're only talking about the things that worked. And a lot of times stuff doesn't work, but they don't post that. People aren't posting all the failures. So this is why sometimes for marketing or people thinking about marketing is think about this as a successful experiment that they did, but this might not work for you. It might don't get demoralized by this because like, hey, it doesn't mean that you suck or your company sucks. It just, maybe this isn't the way that it's going to work for your brand or your service.
有时你在网上读到的或从这些公司看到的东西，他们只谈论那些有效的事情。很多时候事情并不奏效，但他们不会发布这些。人们不会发布所有的失败。这就是为什么有时对于营销或考虑营销的人来说，把这看作是他们做的一次成功的实验，但这可能不适合你。不要因此而气馁，因为嘿，这并不意味着你很糟糕或你的公司很糟糕。这只是意味着，也许这不是适合你的品牌或服务的方法。
Yeah, that totally makes sense. And I believe, correct me if I'm wrong here, but I believe the flywheel comes from like actual, like motor engines where you have this wheel and when the wheel is spinning, so just like a bit of physics stuff to geek out on, you know, if you have an engine with a piston, the way the engine works is when the piston is like in the right spot, it's kind of like pushing a swing, right?
是的，这完全说得通。而且我相信，如果我说错了请纠正我，但我相信飞轮来自实际的，比如汽车发动机，你有一个轮子，当轮子在旋转时，所以就像一点物理知识来极客一下，你知道，如果你有一个带活塞的发动机，发动机的工作方式是当活塞在正确的位置时，它有点像推秋千，对吧？
Like you want to push a swing at the right time. If you push the swing when it's coming back to you, it's just going to slow it down, right? And same kind of thing with the piston, you want to make a little gas explosion at the right time to kind of push the piston the way you'd push a swing on a swing set. And you can't do that if the piston isn't moving, right? And so a flywheel is kind of similar where, you know, you have to, you know, for old motorboats, you'd have to actually pull a cord or, you know, if you have one of those like gas powered lawnmower or something, you would pull a cord to start the wheel. And then once it's going, then the small bursts of energy can kind
就像你想在正确的时间推秋千一样。如果你在秋千向你回来时推它，它只会让它慢下来，对吧？活塞也是一样，你想在正确的时间制造一点气体爆炸，以某种方式推动活塞，就像你在秋千上推秋千一样。如果活塞不动，你就做不到，对吧？所以飞轮有点类似，你知道，你必须，你知道，对于旧的摩托艇，你必须实际拉一根绳子，或者，你知道，如果你有那种燃气割草机之类的东西，你会拉一根绳子来启动轮子。然后一旦它转起来，那么小的能量爆发就可以
of keep it going, but it needs you to kind of kick it off. And the same way, you know, we've talked a lot about this, you know, you might have really great ideas or great companies, but you need marketing to get that wheel going. And then if it's, if it's a really solid plan, then through word of mouth and through things like that, the wheel can even just go on its own, but you need that initial push. Exactly. And yeah, I think marketing just helps you get that initial push. And then once you have marketing, like kind of like we're talking about Zapier right now, right? Think about it. Like they're just getting free press because we love the product. You have a great product plus great marketing. People are going to talk about it and you're going to get tons of more customers. Yeah, that makes sense. So actually, I want to talk about ROI. Before we go into that,
让它继续转动，但它需要你来启动它。同样地，你知道，我们已经谈了很多关于这个的话题，你知道，你可能有非常好的想法或伟大的公司，但你需要营销来让那个轮子转起来。然后如果它是一个非常扎实的计划，那么通过口碑和类似的事情，轮子甚至可以自己转动，但你需要最初的推动。完全正确。而且是的，我认为营销只是帮助你获得最初的推动。然后一旦你有了营销，就像我们现在谈论的 Zapier 一样，对吧？想一想。就像他们只是因为我们喜欢这个产品而获得了免费的媒体报道。你有一个伟大的产品加上伟大的营销。人们会谈论它，你就会得到更多的客户。是的，这很有道理。所以实际上，我想谈谈投资回报率 (ROI)。在我们进入那个话题之前，
what happens with Zapier now? So look at Facebook, for example, or Google. What do their marketing departments do? Because I mean, clearly the brand is ubiquitous, right? So are they done? What did they do at this point? I think what happens with every company is, at least for something like Zapier, it's initially kind of what we said before, Zapier was pretty much like the only one out there. They're the only one that's doing this sort of integration. But now you're probably seeing it too. There's so many Zapier clones coming out now that's pretty much saying like, hey, look,
Zapier 现在怎么样了？所以看看 Facebook，例如，或者谷歌。他们的营销部门做什么？因为我的意思是，显然品牌已经无处不在了，对吧？所以他们完成了吗？他们现在做什么？我认为每家公司都会发生这种情况，至少对于像 Zapier 这样的公司，最初就像我们之前说的那样，Zapier 几乎是市场上唯一的一家。他们是唯一一家做这种集成的人。但现在你可能也看到了。现在出现了这么多 Zapier 的克隆版，几乎都在说，嘿，看，
we're Zapier, but cheaper, right? It's like the typical SaaS thing. We're Zapier, but cheaper, right? So I think right now what's happening with api is they're probably at least from what i've seen is like they're just doing like deeper integrations with certain businesses like enterprise companies uh what i've seen companies do now is like companies like godaddy for example massive like domain name provider so basically what they do is they basically try to get into these backends of these
我们是 Zapier，但更便宜，对吧？这就像典型的 SaaS 事情。我们是 Zapier，但更便宜，对吧？所以我认为现在 api 正在发生的事情是，至少从我所见，他们只是在与某些企业进行更深层次的集成，比如企业级公司。我所看到的公司现在做的事情，比如 GoDaddy，例如，巨大的域名提供商，所以基本上他们所做的是，他们基本上试图进入这些系统的后端，以某种方式建立这些第三方关系，比如深度集成，比如，嘿，当你有一个新网站时，顺便说一下，也为你的公司安装 Zapier。这样你就可以做所有这些疯狂的事情。有点像 WordPress 中的主题，它们是预先构建的，对吧？所以现在它更像是这些企业对企业的营销关系。是的，这完全说得通。我的意思是，我认为一个很好的类比是 iPhone，这有点猜测，所以请持保留态度，但你知道 iPhone 出来了，它就是智能手机，我的意思是它完全占据了主导地位，没有人会再在手机上使用手写笔了。哦，我想除非你有 Galaxy Note。但是是的，所以他们出来了，他们无处不在。现在我认为你开始看到，这回到了
systems to sort of have like these third party relationships, like deep integrations to like, hey, when you have a new website, by the way, also install Zapier for your company. That way you can do all this crazy stuff. Kind of like themes do that in like WordPress where like they're prebuilt, right? So like now it's like more of like these like customer, more like business to business marketing relationships. Yeah, that totally makes sense i mean i think a good parallel to that is the iphone where and this is a bit of speculation so take this with a grain of salt but you know an iphone came out like it was it was the smartphone i mean it just totally dominated like no one was ever going to use a stylus again for their phone oh i guess unless you unless you have the Galaxy Note. But yeah, so they came out and they were just ubiquitous. And now I think you're starting to see, and this loops
你之前提到的 iOS，我想是 14，跟踪、禁用等等，是苹果将开始把自己定位为智能手机中的法拉利，因为来自更便宜的手机（如 Android 和小米等）以及支持这些操作系统的所有硬件的向上压力太大了。所以，是的，苹果正在变得更像一个奢侈品牌，这有点像他们开始的方式。
back to what you said earlier with the iOS, I think it's 14, the tracking, disabling, and all of that, is Apple's going to start positioning themselves as like the Ferrari of smartphones because there's so much upward pressure from, you know, cheaper phones like Android and the Xiaomi and all of that, and all of the hardware that supports those OSs. And so, yeah, Apple is becoming more of like a luxury brand, which is kind of how they started.
所以，是的，我认为 Zapier 可能会做类似的事情，他们会更多地进入企业领域，他们会有点像 IBM，因为就像 IBM 一样，因为即使你能竞争，这也总是一场逐底竞争。所以一旦你不再是新奇的，你就必须改变你的商业模式。是的。而且这也很糟糕，因为 Zapier 对像我们这样的普通消费者来说很棒。它相当便宜。
And so, yeah, I think Zapier might do something similar where they'll get more into enterprise and they'll be kind of like the IBM, because like the IBM because it's very, very hard to, even if you can compete, it's always a race to the bottom. And so you have to change your business model once you're no longer kind of novel. Yeah. And that sucks too, because like Zapier is great for like regular consumers like us. It's pretty cheap.
它相当实惠。但就像我们之前在这个播客中谈到的那样，最终你会进入高端市场，然后使用这个平台变得太贵了。这很糟糕，因为他们有点把像我们这样的用户抛在了后面。是的。是的，完全说得通。所以在我们进入 ROI 之前，也许最好先给出一个背景，你知道，如果有人在那里，也许我会说观众中有两种人，关于营销。有些人，假设他们还在上高中，还在上大学，他们可能有一个很酷的想法，但零资本。所以
It's pretty affordable. But kind of what we were talking about earlier, this podcast, it's like eventually you move up market and then it becomes way too expensive to sort of even use this platform. It sucks because they kind of leave like users like us behind. Yep. Yeah, totally makes sense. So before we get into ROI, maybe it's good to just kind of give a background on, you know, if someone's out there, maybe I'll say there's two kinds of people out there in the audience with respect to marketing. There's people who, let's say they're in high school, they're in college, and they might have a cool idea, but zero, you know, capital. And so
他们想要，你知道，把他们的想法推出去，启动那个飞轮，并真正从零开始启动一些东西。然后还有一些人可能在小企业甚至大企业工作。他们觉得他们听了你的建议，他们想把营销做得更好。你会给这些人什么建议？这可能是相同的建议，也可能是两套不同的建议。是的，我认为，假设有人想做营销或想测试一些东西。基本上，我有一个朋友现在想卖一个产品，她说，哦，我想卖这个产品。基本上生产、制造它，然后还要获得标签，这要花我大约 15 万美元。真的
they want to, you know, get their idea out there, start that flywheel and kind of really kickstart something from the ground up. And then there's also people who might work at a small business or even a large business. And they feel like they've listened to you and they want to do marketing better. What sort of advice would you give to those people? It could be the same or it could be two different sets of advice. Yeah, I think like, let's say someone wants to do marketing or wants to test something out. And basically, I have a friend right now that wants to sell a product product and she's like, oh, I want to sell this product. It's going to cost me like 150K to basically get it produced, manufacture it, and then also get the labeling. And really
我告诉她的是这个。我说，嘿，想想如果你有那个产品或服务你会怎么做，假装你拥有它。建立你的网站，建立你的推特账户，建立你的 Instagram 账户，上传视频，创意，然后试着像你真的有那个产品或服务一样去营销它。因为你现在真正想做的是学习，人们真的想买这个东西吗？这就是我现在告诉企业主或创始人的地方，试着看看这是否有真正的需求。你可以投放广告，Facebook 广告或谷歌广告来看看，你能做到吗？而且关于这一点，如果这让你感到沮丧，你做不到，那么也许你卖不掉这个产品。因为即使我们是一家广告代理公司，我们为创始人做广告，我们合作过的最好的创始人
what I told her was this. I was like, hey, think about what would you do if you had that product or service and pretend that you have it. Get your website up, get your Twitter account up, get your Instagram account up, get the videos up, creatives up, and then actually try to market it as if you had that product or service. Because really what you want to do now is learn, do people actually want to buy this thing or not? And that's really where I tell business owners or founders right now is try to see if there's actually demand for this. And you can run ads, Facebook ads or Google ads to see, can you do this? And the thing about this too is if this sort of frustrates you and you can't do it, then maybe you can't sell the product. Because even though we're an ad agency and we do ads for founders, the best founders
实际上是和我们一起做营销。我们在这里帮助他们，因为我们总是告诉人们，你比我们更了解你的业务。你比我们更关心它。是的，我们和你一起工作。但我的意思是，你们可能知道，就像你们作为你们的公司，它就像你们的孩子。你考虑它的次数比我们考虑的要多。对我们来说，好吧，让我们每天考虑两三个小时。对你来说，你 24 小时都在考虑它。所以你帮助代理机构或你合作的任何人进行营销，并学习营销，这也有一定的道理。这样你就能真正理解 A/B 测试、创意测试、角度测试、落地页。对于你这样一个刚开始的人，先做所有这些事情，看看你是否能为你的产品或服务获得某种需求。这样，
that we work with are actually doing the marketing themselves with us. And we're there to help them because we always tell people, you know your business better than we will ever do. You care about it more than we'll ever do. Like, yes, we're working with you. But I mean, you guys probably know it's like you as your company, it's like your baby. You think about it more than we'll ever think about it. For us, okay, let's think about it for two, three hours a day. For you, you're thinking about 24 hours a day. So there's something to be said about you also helping the agency or anybody you're working with, with the marketing and also learning about marketing. That way you truly understand A-B testing, creative testing, angle testing, landing pages. And really for you, someone starting out, do all this stuff first and see if you can try to get some sort of demand for your product or service. And this way,
你就不必把所有的钱都花在一些潜在的你知道你可以试着为你的产品或服务获得某种需求的东西上。这样，你就不必把所有的钱都花在一些潜在的你知道你卖不掉的东西上，或者你基本上只是发现没有角度或市场。是的，完全说得通。所以我的意思是，我不认为你需要很多钱来开始。所以假设你在上高中，你有一些想法，
you don't have to spend all this money on something that potentially you know that you can try to get some sort of demand for your product or service. And this way, you don't have to spend all this money on something that potentially you know that you can't sell or that you essentially just maybe figure out that there's no angle or market for. Yeah, totally makes sense. So I mean, I don't think you need a lot of money to get this started. So let's say you're in high school, you have some idea,
你预留了大约 50 美元。你说，我要投放 Facebook 广告，或者也许你甚至只是免费查看，你可以查看谷歌趋势，或者尝试在你的落地页上运行谷歌分析。你可以尝试，你知道，爬上寻找人们真正想要的那个利基市场。这不需要很多很多钱来做到这一点。是的，完全正确。而且我认为这也是最好的开始方式。就像，用那笔钱来测试你的产品或服务，因为最糟糕的事情可能是，我也见过这种情况，有人在产品上投资了 1 到 2 万美元，比如电子商务产品，然后他们找不到人来买
you set aside maybe $50. You say, I'm gonna run Facebook ads or maybe you even just look at for free, you can look at, Google trends or try and look to run Google analytics on your landing page. And you could try to, you know, climb your way up to finding that niche that people really want. And it doesn't take a lot, a lot to do that. Yeah, exactly. And I think that is the best way to start too. It's like, use that money to test your product or service because the worst thing that could happen is, and I've seen this before too, it's someone invests 10 to 20K on a product, like an e-commerce product, and then they can't find people to buy
它。然后他们被困在车库里一年，对吧？是的。是的。是的，完全正确。我的意思是，我们见过，我们见过比这更多的故事。看看 Juicero。是的。太疯狂了。是的。天哪。所以只是背景介绍一下，Juicero，它就像一个榨汁机，你必须购买这些非常特定的东西。所以你为榨汁机支付了很多钱，然后它会送到你家。你会买这些看起来很奇怪的包，榨汁机基本上会挤出这些包。而且还有 DRM。所以他们有保护。
it. And then they're stuck with this in their garage for like a year, right? Yep. Yep. Yeah, exactly. I mean, we've seen, and we've seen like even more stories than that. I mean, look at like Juicero. Yeah. I was crazy. Yeah. Oh my God. So just some background, Juicero, it was like a juicer where you would have to buy these very specifically. So you'd pay a ton for the juicer and then it would arrive at your house. You'd buy these like weird looking packets and the juicer would basically squeeze out these packets. And there was also like DRM. So they had protection.
就像如果你买了别人的包，你知道，榨汁机就会像，你知道，对你摇手指。而且它提供的价值为零，就像拿一个橙子挤压它一样，对吧？是的，你知道，实际上，我甚至不知道如何将它与营销联系起来，因为在某种意义上，他们甚至能够达到他们所处的位置是一个巨大的营销胜利，但另一方面，就像，是的，我的意思是，我认为从小处着手并
Like if you bought someone else's packet, you know, the juicer would like, you know, wag its finger at you. And like it provided like zero value over just like taking an orange and squeezing it right yeah you know and actually what you know i don't even know how how to relate that to marketing because in one sense it was a huge marketing victory that they were even able to get to where they were but on the other hand it's like yeah i mean i think starting small and
意识到，是的，那个市场在自然状态下真的不存在。我的意思是，你可以让人们对几乎任何事情感到兴奋，但是，你知道，产品市场根本不存在。弄清楚它。你可以花 50 美元弄清楚这一点，并为 Juicero 省下数百万美元。是的。Juicero 的故事太搞笑了，因为我想现在听的人，这真的向你展示了营销对一个像哑弹一样的产品也有效。就像字面上有人制作了一个 YouTube 视频，对吧？那只是说，嘿，我为什么需要 Juicero？为什么我不能直接挤那个袋子？
realizing that yeah that that market just really isn't there organically. I mean, you can get people excited about just about anything, but, but you know, the product market is just not there. Just figure it. You can figure that out for 50 bucks and have saved Juicero millions. Yeah. The Juicero story was so funny because like, I guess people listening right now that literally shows you that marketing works for a product that's like a dud. It's like literally someone made a YouTube video, right? That was just like, hey, why do I need you, Sarah? Why can't I just squeeze the bag?
人们就像，哦，是的，你可以直接挤那个袋子。那太搞笑了。但是的，这向你展示了营销可以用于善或恶，对吧？他们用它筹集了什么，数亿美元，来自顶级风投公司之一。是的，那是对的。我有一个故事，我的意思是，这个人不会被冒犯，我不认为，这是我的一个朋友，我不会说是谁，但他们在为 Pebble 工作，呃，Pebble 你知道倒闭了，我想他们被收购了，但这有点像清仓大甩卖，你知道他们有点哀叹他们加入了 Pebble，就像，哦，我做了一个错误的决定。
And people are like, oh, yeah, you can just squeeze the bag. That was so funny. But yeah, that kind of shows you marketing could be used for good or evil, right? And they used it to raise, what, hundreds of millions of dollars, from like one of the top vc firms yeah that's right i have a story i mean this is a this person won't get offended i don't think it's a friend of mine and i won't say who it is but they were working for pebble and uh pebble you know went out of business i think they were acquired but it was kind of a fire sale you know they're kind of lamenting that they joined pebble it's like oh i kind of made a bad decision.
我告诉他们，好吧，你知道，没有什么你真的，这完全超出了你的领域。我的意思是，他是一名硬件工程师，所以他不太了解产品。然后他告诉我，这是几年前的事了，他告诉我，哦，但我得到了这个好工作，
And I was telling them, well, you know, there's nothing you really, it's totally out of your domain. I mean, he's a hardware engineer, so he's not too plugged into the product. And then he told me, and this was years ago, and he told me, oh, but I got this good gig,
所以我感觉没那么糟糕。我说，哦，你要去哪里？他说，Juicero。天哪。我说，哦，不。天哪。那太疯狂了。是的。所以这向你展示了营销有效，他们做到了。我不知道团队是什么样的。我会去找到 Juicero 团队的那些营销人员。就像，嘿，你能营销我的产品吗？因为你做对了什么。是的。是的。这是真的。所以人们怎么，
so I don't feel too bad. I'm like, oh, where are you going? He said, Juicero. Oh my God. I was like, oh no. Jesus. That was so crazy. Yeah. So that shows you marketing works and they did it. I don't know what the team was like. I would go find those marketers on the Juicero team. Like, Hey, can you market my product? Because you did something right. Yeah. Yeah. It's so true. So how do people,
你知道，假设我们，这个，这个假设我们做了那个。而且，所以无论我们是花 50 美元还是花 10 万美元，嗯，我们如何衡量我们是否从那里面得到了某种回报？我觉得这个问题实际上很难回答，对吧？因为它是完全反事实的。就像你必须说，你知道，如果我不投放这个广告，这些人还会来我的网站吗？而且，因为我投放了广告，有多少人还是来了我的网站？而且因为我投放了广告，有多少人没有使用广告就来到了我的网站，因为他们和别人谈过？这是一种部分可观察的反事实评估。回答这个问题似乎几乎是不可能的，对吧？这个问题太难回答了，因为对于每家企业，它取决于他们试图做什么。对吧。所以例如，我们与一些风投支持的公司合作
you know, let's say that we, this, this let's say we do that. And, and so whether we're spending $50 or we're spending a hundred thousand dollars, um, you know, how do we measure if we're getting kind of a return on that? I feel like that question is actually difficult to answer, right? Because it's totally counterfactual. Like you would have to say, you know, if I didn't run this ad, would these people have come to my website anyways? And, and, and because I ran the ad, how many people have come to my website anyways? And because I ran the ad, how many people came to my website not using the ad because they talked to somebody? It's this partially observable, counterfactual evaluation. It just seems almost impossible to answer that, right? That question is so hard to answer because for every business, it depends on kind of like what they're trying to do. Right. So for example, we work with some VC funded companies
就像你已经知道的那样，他们关心的只是增长，而 ROI 并不是他们真正关心的数字。他们只是想说，嘿，我们只是想获得比竞争对手更多的客户，但以后我们会弄清楚这一点。对吧。所以根据你的业务，根据基本上营销就像你想花多少钱来获得一个客户，以及在你破产之前你能承受多少？对吧。所以这很有道理。所以基本上，但你应该考虑 ROI 的方式，因为我们确实与很多创始人合作，那是他们自己的钱。当那是你自己的钱时，你要确保你是盈利的。关于它的是计算你所有的运营成本。好的。你给自己发多少钱？你给员工发多少钱？你为你的仓库，为你的运输支付多少钱，对吧？如果你在做电子商务，商品的原始成本是多少？然后弄清楚那些
and like you already know, like all they care about is growth and ROI is not really a number they care about. They just want to say, Hey, we just want to acquire more customers that are competitors, but later on we'll sort of figure that out. Right. So depending on your business, depending on basically marketing is kind of like how much money do you want to spend to acquire a customer and how much can you stomach before you become broke? Right. So that makes sense. So basically, but the way you should be thinking about ROI, because we do work with a lot of founders that it's their own money. When it's your own money, you want to make sure that you're profitable. about it is calculate all your operating costs. Okay. How much are you paying yourself? How much are you paying your staff? How much are you sort of maybe for your warehouse, for your shipping, right? If you're doing e-commerce, what are the raw costs of goods? And then figure out what those
商品的原始成本是多少，然后弄清楚你想卖多少钱，然后找到你的利润率。然后这就是你可以说的数字，比如，嘿，让我们有一个 100 美元的插件。它花了我 50 美元全部制造和运输它。这意味着对于营销支出，你只能花 50 美元来获得一个客户。如果你花了 50 美元，这意味着你收支平衡了。这意味着你获得了一个客户，但你没有赚到任何钱。现在，如果你花 30 美元获得一个客户，这意味着你现在赚了 20 美元的利润。所以现在你可以说，嘿，这太棒了。
raw costs of goods are and then figure out how much you want to sell it for and then find your profit margin. And then that's sort of like the number that you can say like, hey, let's have a $100 widget. It cost me $50 all in to manufacture and ship it. So that means for marketing spend, you can only spend $50 to acquire a customer. And if you spend 50, that means you broke even. And that means you sort of got one customer, but you didn't make any money. Now, if you spend 30 bucks to acquire a customer, that means now you made $20 in profit. So now you can say, hey, this is great.
这个营销渠道对我来说很有效，因为我正在盈利地获得客户。但其他时候，你可能想花 50 美元来获得客户而不收支平衡，因为你知道在未来，你有另一个产品可以卖给他们。所以这确实是更多 SaaS 公司所做的，他们会试图雇佣收支平衡的客户
This marketing channel is working for me because I'm acquiring customers profitably. But other times you might want to spend $50 to acquire the customer and not break even because you know that down the line, you have another product that you can sell to them. So then this is really what more SaaS companies do is they will sort of try to hire customers that break even
因为他们知道在未来，他们可以将他们升级到更多计划或添加某种追加销售。但真正实现 ROI 盈利，取决于你的商业模式以及你银行里有多少钱来负担营销，或者你处于增长的哪个阶段。因为即使你是一家自力更生的初创公司，有时你也想增长得更快，因为你可以出售你的公司。所以你想展示增长数字，对吧？并获得更高的估值等等。是的，这完全说得通。我认为另一件事是，你知道，这是另一件可能真的很难衡量，但非常重要的事情是边际化因素，对吧？就像，你可能会从
because they know that later down the line, they can upgrade them to more plans or add some sort of upsells. But really becoming ROI profitable, it depends on your business model and sort of how much money you have in the bank to sort of afford marketing or what stage of growth you are. Because even if you're a bootstrap startup, sometimes you want to grow faster because you could be selling your company. So you want to show growth numbers, right? And get a higher valuation and stuff like that. Yeah, it totally makes sense. I think another thing too is, you know, it's another thing that's probably really difficult to measure, but really important is the marginalization factor, right? Like it's, you probably get
花 10 美元中获得更多价值，而不是从花 20 美元中获得价值，你并不总是能从花 20 美元中获得两倍的价值。对吧。所以当你开始花得越来越多时，我的猜测是每一美元带给你的价值会越来越少。就像当你买几乎任何东西时，这都是真的。这是非常真实的。是的。当你花得更多时，就像在开始时，你获得了很多伟大的胜利，非常高的 ROI。
more value out of spending $10 and out of spending, you don't get two times the value for spending $20 all the time. Right. So like as you start spending more and more, my guess is each dollar will get you for like less and less. Like that's just true when you buy almost anything. That's very true. Yeah. As you spend more, like in the beginning, it's like you get lots of great wins, very high ROI.
然后当你花更多的钱时，它变得越来越少，对吧？是的。有什么工具可以衡量这一点吗？还是逐案处理，像全球性的？你开发过任何全球性的见解吗，还是这只是你每次都必须衡量并看看会发生什么的事情？对我们来说，就像我们一直在与一些公司合作，至少在这里，他们每月在 Facebook 广告上花费超过一百万美元，而且效果仍然相当不错。而对于一些公司来说，这并不好。这真的取决于。这就是为什么我认为
And then as you spend more money, it becomes like less and less, right? Yeah. Are there any tools to measure that? Or is it on a case-by-case basis, like global? Have you developed any like global insights or is it just something you have to measure each time and see what happens? For us, like we've been working with some companies, at least for here that like spend over a million dollars a month on Facebook ads and it's still pretty good. Whereas for some companies it's not good. It just really depends. And this is why I think
对于听众来说，考虑不同的渠道非常重要。比如 SEO，例如，我们谈到了 SEO，但那，我的意思是，你可能知道那是一个可能在第二年或第三年才有效的渠道。所以前两年，你不要指望从中获得任何 ROI，因为你不会得到任何回报。这就是为什么培养这种渠道肌肉是有意义的。当你做更多的业务时，你说，好吧，让我现在开始 SEO，因为对于我之前的业务，我知道它花了我一年半的时间。所以让我们在明年开始 Facebook 广告来引入客户，同时那个 SEO 飞轮启动。是的，这很有道理。我的意思是，这超级超级迷人。
for people listening, it's very important to just be thinking about different channels. Like SEO, for example, we talked about SEO, but that, I mean, you probably know that's a channel that maybe works year two or three. So the first two years, you don't expect any ROI on that because you're not going to get any. So this is why developing this muscle for channels makes sense. As you make more businesses, you say, okay, let me start SEO now because for my previous business, I know it took me a year and a half. So let's start Facebook ads for the next year to bring in customers while that SEO flywheel kicks in. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah. I mean, this is super, super fascinating.
所以对于那些刚开始并想自己尝试其中一些的人，我的意思是，我们提到了 Zapier，我们提到了，你提到的无头 CMS 是什么？所以我们使用 Launch27。Launch27。对于那些，也许他们已经构建了他们的第一个应用程序，并且它是一个提供一些缺失价值并确实可以为人们增加价值的应用程序的人来说，有哪些好的营销工具？而且人们只需要知道它，你知道，他们可能在营销方面零背景。所以，你知道，其中一些，比如投放 Facebook 广告，你真的不需要工具。我认为，正如你提到的，Photoshop 可能非常重要，以确保你有一个好的、漂亮的缩略图等等。但除了像文本编辑器和照片编辑器之外，还有什么工具你推荐人们用来营销他们的应用程序或网站，特别是做
So for people who are just starting out and want to try some of this on their own, I mean, we mentioned Zapier and we mentioned, what was the headless CMS that you mentioned? So we use Launch27. Launch27. What are some good marketing tools for folks who are, maybe they have built their first app and it's an app that provides some value that is missing and really can add value to people. And the people just have to kind of know about it, you know, and they might have zero background in marketing. So, you know, some of this, like running a Facebook ad, you don't really need a tool for that. I think, as you mentioned, Photoshop is probably really important to make sure you have a good, a nice thumbnail and everything. But beyond just like the text editor and the photo editor, like are there tools that you recommend for people to, you know, market their app or their site and especially do the
跟踪等等？是的，我会说我喜欢使用的最好的工具之一，它叫 Ahrefs。你们听说过吗？A-H-R-E-F-S 点 com。它有点像 H-R-E-S-S 的锚点东西。我知道，我从来没听说过。它叫 Ahrefs。Ahrefs.com。Ahrefs，是的。这是我最喜欢的营销工具。对于人们来说，它相当昂贵。每月大约 180 美元。但真的有了这个工具，它基本上给了你，它就像商业智能工具。如果你有一个竞争对手，如果他们有一个网站，你可以把它插入他们的服务，它会告诉你他们获得了多少流量，他们正在为哪些关键词排名，他们正在运行什么谷歌广告，谷歌广告的文本。
tracking and all of that? Yeah, I would say one of the best tools that I love using, it's called Ahrefs. Have you guys heard of it? A-H-R-E-F-S dot com. It's like kind of like the anchor thing for H-R-E-S-S. I know, I've never heard of that. It's called Ahrefs. Ahrefs.com. Ahrefs, yep. It's my favorite marketing tool. It's pretty pricey just for people to understand. It's about 180 a month. But really with this tool, it basically gives you like, it's like business intelligence tool. If you have a competitor out there, if they have a website, you can plug it into their service and it'll tell you how much traffic they're getting, what keywords they're ranking for, what Google ads are running, the text of the Google ads.
所以你可以看到他们是如何营销产品的，他们正在运行什么落地页，它让你深入了解他们是如何增长的。所以你也可以看到他们的增长轨迹，长达一年左右。所以这可能是任何人都可以使用的我最喜欢的工具之一。而且字面上你可以监视任何人，对吧？所以你可以看看 apple.com，看看，哦，哇，他们增长得太快了，对吧？哦，非常酷。我见过一个非常针对软件的。它叫 BuiltWith。你可以去 BuiltWith 查看趋势等等。是的，BuiltWith 很棒。但想一想，是的，这有点像 BuiltWith。
So you can see like how they're marketing the product, what landing pages they're running, and it gives you insights into how they're growing. So you can see like their growth trajectory as well up to like a year or so. So this is probably one of my favorite tools out there that anybody could use. And literally like you can spy anybody, right? So you can look at like apple.com and see like, oh, wow, they're growing so fast, right? Oh, very cool. I've seen one that's very specific to software. It's called BuiltWith. And you can go to BuiltWith and see the trends and everything. Yeah. BuiltWith is awesome. But think about it like, yeah, this is kind of like a BuiltWith.
我认为 Ahrefs，它更用户友好。我认为 BuiltWith 就像超级开发者。所以是的，我使用那个。然后我认为下一个最好的工具只是谷歌关键词规划师。这是谷歌的一个免费工具。它基本上允许你插入任何关键词，它会显示你的搜索量。我认为我希望人们理解的最大事情是理解业务、产品、
I think Ahrefs, it's more user-friendly. I think BuiltWith is like super developer. So yeah, I use that. And then the next best tool I think is just Google Keyword Planner. It's a free tool by Google. And it basically allows you to plug in whatever keyword and it shows you the volume. I think the biggest thing that I want people to understand is understanding search volume of a business, of a product,
服务的搜索量将真正让你知道，我应该构建这个还是不应该构建这个？如果搜索量是 10，也许需求不大，但它可能会上升，对吧？这很好。所以随着时间的推移跟踪它。然后再次，你可以使用它来查看，例如，made service NYC。我想我们每月大约有 500 次搜索。然后我们就像，哦，这相当不错。人们正在搜索这项服务。我可以在这个领域做一个产品，因为对我想要销售的这项服务有需求。是的。这是一个非常好的观点。所以关键词规划师与谷歌趋势有什么不同？我认为谷歌趋势更多是关于，我想它们实际上非常相似，但我认为谷歌关键词规划师有更多数据，因为它基于谷歌 AdWords 数据。
of a service will really allow you to know, should I build this or should I not build this? If search volume is like 10, maybe there's not much demand, but it could be going up, right? Which is great. So track that over time. And then again, you could use this to sort of see like, for example, made service NYC. I think we get about 500 searches a month. And then we're like, Oh, this is pretty good. Like people are searching for this service. I can make a product in this space because there's demand for this service that I want to sell. Yeah. That's a really good point. So it's how is keyword planner different than Google trends? I think Google trends is more about, I think they're pretty similar actually, but I think Google keyword planner has more data because it's based out of Google AdWords data.
啊，明白了。现在，另一件事是，你可能有一个想法，你通常不知道正确的，假设，表达该数据的语言。例如，Zapier，你可能会说一些非常技术性的东西，比如 API 加入平台。结果证明，即使你有正确的想法，也没有人真的，客户实际上并没有使用那种语言，对吧？所以你可以玩弄一些相邻的术语，并以某种方式爬上寻找，比如，什么，当我的客户，你知道，在搜索时，比如，当他们真正
Ah, got it. Now, the other thing too is you might have an idea and you often don't know the right, let's say, language to express that data. For example, Zapier, you might say something pretty technical like API joining platform. And it turns out even though you have the right idea, no one's actually, the customers aren't actually using that language, right? And so you could play around with like adjacent terms and kind of climb your way up to finding out like, what, when my customer, you know, is searching, like, what are they searching when they actually
想要我的产品时，他们在搜索什么？完全正确。而且我认为你说的，Jason，非常重要，因为我们作为开发者或创造者，我们想用我们的方式命名事物，但没有人那样称呼它。而且就像，有时你只需要回到基础，比如，正常人类称呼事物的方式是什么，对吧？是的。是的，完全正确。是的。而且我认为有时价值，特别是在软件中，有时某事的价值
want my product? Exactly. And I think what you said, Jason, is so important because us as developers or creators, we want to name things our way, but no one calls it that. And it's like, sometimes you just got to go back to the basics of like, what are normal humans calling things, right? Yeah. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. And I think sometimes the value, especially in software, sometimes the value of something
是你有点像把复杂的事情变得非常简单。所以就像想象一下，如果你正在使用一些非常复杂的，比如长期、短期记忆，你知道，神经网络，但你真的在尝试做异常检测。此外，如果你开始插入像 LTSM 神经网络，它就像你，你错过了受众。就像重点是受众不想考虑那个。他们想要异常检测。是的。这太神奇了。有时你把事情放入关键词规划师，你意识到就像，
is that you're kind of like making something complicated, really simple. So like imagine if you're using like some really complicated, like long-term, short-term memory, you know, neural network, but you're really trying to do anomaly detection. Also, if you start plugging in like LTSM neural network, it's're, it's like you're, you're missing the audience. Like the whole point is the audience doesn't want to think about that. They want anomaly detection. Yeah. It's amazing. Sometimes you put things into keyword planner and you realize like,
哦，这称呼某事的最流行方式。是的，完全正确。它太，它太好了。它太棒了。我喜欢使用关键词规划师。
Oh, like this is the most popular way to call something. Yeah, exactly. It's so, it's so good. It's so awesome. I love using keyword planner.
酷。是的。我从来没听说过那个。我一定会去看看。而且我认为，我认为你，你，你很准确，谷歌趋势
Cool. Yeah. I've never heard of that. I'm definitely going to check it out. And I think, I think you're, you're, you're spot on that the Google Trends
可能更多是他们通过扫描新闻页面等做的事情，这将非常偏向于新闻和上新闻的事情，而关键词规划师将真正与人们正在搜索的内容更相关，这才是你在做 SEO 时真正重要的。是的。它非常重要。我一直告诉人们，你一直在搜索东西。想一想。你是怎么找到东西的？这就是你想要你的品牌或服务所在的地方，因为人们每天都在搜索。是的，这很有道理。所以除了
is probably more something they did from scanning news pages and stuff, which is going to be pretty biased to news and things that make the news versus Keyword Planner is really going to be more connected, like correlated to what people are searching for, which is really what matters when you're doing SEO. Yeah. It matters so much. And I tell people all the time, you search for things all the time. Think about it. How do you find things? And that's where you want your brand to be or service be because people search every single day. Yeah. That makes sense. And so besides the
made business，你有 Voi Media。所以那是像一个人的操作还是你有一群人？它是怎么运作的？是的。对于 Voi Media，我们帮助其他企业投放广告。所以是的，Voi Media 现在，我的公司，我们有大约 40 名员工在那里为我工作。太酷了。所以那是什么样的？
made business, you have Voi Media. And so is that like a solo operation or do you have a team of folks? How does that work? Yeah. So for Voi Media, we help like other businesses with ads. So yeah, Voi Media right now, my company, we have about 40 employees that work for me there. So cool. And so what's that like?
创办了企业，你还有 Voi Media。那是你个人的独立运营，还是有一个团队？具体是怎么运作的？是的，对于 Voi Media，我们帮助其他企业投放广告。所以，是的，Voi Media 目前是我自己的公司，我们大约有 40 名员工在那里为我工作。太酷了。那感觉怎么样？
Well, I mean, no, now, now it's with COVID. So, so let's, let's rewind the clock and go pre-COVID. And so what is a day like? If it's in New York City, it's probably like maybe in a high rise or something. But what's it like to work at Voi Media? Yeah, so for working at Voi, really, we help clients with a bunch of their Facebook ads. That's like the number one thing that we do for them. It's when we say Facebook ads too, really what we're doing now is really managing all the creatives for them. It's when we say Facebook ads too, really what we're doing now is really managing all the
嗯，我的意思是，不，现在，现在是因为新冠疫情。所以，让我们把时钟拨回新冠疫情之前。那么，一天是怎样的呢？如果是在纽约市，可能是在高层建筑里之类的。但在 Voi Media 工作是什么感觉？是的，在 Voi 工作，我们确实帮助客户处理大量的 Facebook 广告。这是我们为他们做的第一件事。当我们说 Facebook 广告时，我们现在真正做的是为他们管理所有的创意素材。当我们说 Facebook 广告时，我们现在真正做的是为他们管理
creatives for them, how we're going to sell their product creatively with videos, images, and then we upload that to Facebook to market to them. But usually what we're coming up with for clients is different hooks, different angles. And we're also thinking about different ways for them to sell a product with funnels. Like maybe they need a sales page. Maybe they need like an advertorial. Maybe they need a quiz funnel. Maybe they need like an advertorial. Maybe they need a quiz funnel. So that's kind of what we do here at Voi is really thinking about them. But really for us,
所有的创意素材，我们如何通过视频、图片创造性地销售他们的产品，然后我们将这些上传到 Facebook 进行营销。但通常我们为客户想出的是不同的钩子、不同的角度。我们也在考虑通过漏斗销售产品的不同方式。比如他们可能需要一个销售页面。可能需要一篇软文。可能需要一个测验漏斗。可能需要一篇软文。可能需要一个测验漏斗。所以这就是我们在 Voi 所做的事情，真正为他们着想。但对我们来说，
the brands that we work with are more like, hey, we have a proven product that we've sold before. How can you guys make it better? We don't really work with too many brands that are just kind of brand new because we just know this, that we can't help those companies at the moment with the way we do things. That makes it, that really resonates with me.
我们合作的品牌更像是，嘿，我们有一个经过验证的产品，我们以前卖过。你们怎么能把它做得更好？我们并没有与太多刚起步的品牌合作，因为我们知道，以我们目前的工作方式，我们无法帮助那些公司。这让我很有共鸣。
My day job, I do, I do machine learning and decision-making AI. And so occasionally we'll get people like, you know, other people in the company, other teams coming to us, you know, asking for our help. And the first thing we tell them is do something simple by yourself. Like before you bring in the AI department, do something really simple and let's see what happens. And I think, you know, that sounds like that kind of translates here as well. Like there's a lot that people can do, businesses can do, or even people can do on their own and a lot they can learn. And that might not take a lot of money, but it definitely takes a lot of time. And so I know, I mean, from the podcast, I mean, we went something
我的日常工作是做机器学习和决策人工智能。所以偶尔会有公司里的其他人、其他团队来找我们寻求帮助。我们告诉他们的第一件事就是自己先做一些简单的事情。在引入人工智能部门之前，先做一些非常简单的事情，看看会发生什么。我认为，这在这里也适用。人们可以做很多事情，企业可以做很多事情，甚至个人也可以自己做很多事情，并且可以学到很多东西。这可能不需要很多钱，但绝对需要很多时间。我知道，从播客来看，我们经历了大约
like two years where it was just our moms listening. And actually, I'm sure there were other people too. So I don't want to, if you're a long time listener, it's not like a shove or anything. But there was definitely a chunk of time where the podcast was just getting bootstrapped. And I don't think that a huge marketing push on episode number three would have really made a difference. So definitely, folks out there, there's so much that you have to do on your own,
两年的时间，只有我们的妈妈在听。实际上，我相信还有其他人。所以，如果你是一位长期听众，我不是在贬低什么。但确实有一段时间，播客只是在起步阶段。我不认为在第三集进行大规模的营销推广会有什么真正的不同。所以，对于外面的朋友们，你们必须自己做很多事情，
but that also means that the flip side of that is there's so much you can do as an individual. And then once you have that flywheel going, once you kind of understand your market and your audience and what they're looking for, then if you're making, as Kevin said, if you're making money on each acquisition, then you can give Void Media a call and they can take it to the next level. Yeah. And it goes, yeah, I think people all the time, it's really, when people do it themselves and they kind of learn a little bit about it because it makes just working with that marketing or freelancer so much easier. And yeah, there's so much more
但这也意味着，另一方面，作为个人，你可以做很多事情。一旦你有了那个飞轮，一旦你了解了你的市场、你的受众以及他们想要什么，那么正如 Kevin 所说，如果你在每次获客上都能赚钱，那么你就可以给 Voi Media 打电话，他们可以将其提升到一个新的水平。是的。而且，我认为人们总是这样，当人们自己做并学习一点相关知识时，因为这会让与营销人员或自由职业者合作变得容易得多。是的，还有更多
that you could do. And I tell people all the time, if you're going to make some sort of channel, like the main way to acquire customers, I think that you should probably want to know how it works. That way you're like, you truly understand how your business is growing. So I think it's so important. Yeah. Yeah, that also resonates. I think a lot of people want really complicated AI, like Salesforce has Einstein, they have the Einstein platform and everything. But the thing is, at the end of the day,
你可以做的事情。我总是告诉人们，如果你要建立某种渠道作为获取客户的主要方式，我认为你应该了解它是如何运作的。这样你就能真正了解你的业务是如何增长的。所以我认为这非常重要。是的。是的，这也引起了共鸣。我认为很多人想要非常复杂的人工智能，比如 Salesforce 有 Einstein，他们有 Einstein 平台等等。但问题是，归根结底，
like you need to be able to know what is going on. Like you need to have something that's interpretable and you can't just throw everything into a machine because as soon as that machine stops working, which doesn't mean there's a bug per se, it could be maybe people lost interest, but for whatever reason, as soon as that machine stops working,
你需要能够知道发生了什么。你需要有一些可解释的东西，你不能只是把所有东西都扔进机器里，因为一旦机器停止工作，这并不意味着本身有错误，可能是人们失去了兴趣，但无论出于什么原因，一旦机器停止工作，
you're going to be stuck. Yeah. And you're not going to have gained those insights you really needed to make that pivot earlier that would have prevented that. Yeah, exactly. And the thing too that I'll learn is that like anything, you guys probably know, some of this stuff sounds scary.
你就会陷入困境。是的。而且你将无法获得那些你真正需要的洞察力来更早地进行调整，从而避免这种情况。是的，完全正确。而且我学到的另一件事是，像任何事情一样，你们可能知道，其中一些东西听起来很可怕。
Like, oh my God, we're saying Zapier, we're saying this. Once you dig into it, you're like, oh, this is really easy. Yeah, and the other thing too is don't get really agoraphobic. I see so many threads on either Stack Overflow or Reddit on, I can't decide what game engine to use for this game or i can't decide whether to use ruby or flask and and it's like i've spent like 200 hours and here's my blog post on it and it's like i mean that's that's cool it's it's a value that you're providing but but you can also just pick anything and just run with it
比如，天哪，我们在说 Zapier，我们在说这个。一旦你深入研究，你会发现，哦，这真的很简单。是的，还有一件事是不要变得过于焦虑。我在 Stack Overflow 或 Reddit 上看到很多帖子，关于我无法决定为这个游戏使用什么游戏引擎，或者我无法决定是使用 Ruby 还是 Flask，就像我花了 200 个小时，这是我的博客文章，这很酷，这是你提供的价值，但你也可以随便选一个就开始做，
and uh you will learn so much no matter what. I mean, even Kevin and I both built things from scratch and went through all that pain. And sure, in hindsight, it would have been much easier to use WordPress, but we learned so much from that experience. And so you can always just pick up anything and run with it. And one thing that Kevin has provided as a really good product is this Digital Marketing Made Easy, which is a book that's, is it on Amazon? Yeah, it's on Amazon. Yep. Cool. Yeah, it's on Amazon. How does that book kind of, where does it start off?
无论如何你都会学到很多。我的意思是，即使 Kevin 和我都从零开始构建东西，并经历了所有的痛苦。当然，事后看来，使用 WordPress 会容易得多，但我们从那次经历中学到了很多。所以你总是可以随便选一个就开始做。Kevin 提供的一个非常好的产品是《数字营销变得简单》，这是一本书，它在亚马逊上吗？是的，它在亚马逊上。是的。酷。是的，它在亚马逊上。那本书是从哪里开始的？
Does it kind of explain like Marketing 101 and kind of dive in from there? Yeah, basically the book explains Marketing 101. It talks about, you know, kind of why you need marketing, like what's, what's a growth strategy, what are the different channels you could use, right? And the basic kind of talks about like SEO, Facebook ads, Google ads, content marketing. It kind of just tells people like, Hey, here are things that you should be thinking about when starting a business. And then we kind of like dive into like each of these tactics that you could do. And then overall it says like, these are all things that you could do, figure one out that you want to try. And then if it doesn't work, move on to the next one. Or if it does work,
它是否解释了营销 101 之类的东西，然后从那里深入探讨？是的，基本上这本书解释了营销 101。它谈到了你为什么需要营销，什么是增长策略，你可以使用哪些不同的渠道，对吧？基础部分谈到了 SEO、Facebook 广告、Google 广告、内容营销。它只是告诉人们，嘿，这些是你开始创业时应该考虑的事情。然后我们深入探讨了你可以采取的每一种策略。总的来说，它说，这些都是你可以做的事情，找出你想尝试的一种。如果它不起作用，就换下一个。或者如果它起作用了，
keep the other one running and then move on to the next channel. It's, it's, that's sort of like the book is about. Cool. And so is it, actually, I don't know, you would definitely know this, but does Amazon automatically take your book and I guess they can't make an audio book out of it automatically, but is it on like Kindle and paperback and hardback, like hardcover? Is it all those formats? I wish it was audio. Cause I want the audio, but they're like, Kevin, you need to record it. I'm like, okay, this is like four or 500 pages. I was like, yeah. There's this Amazon Polly, which is amazingly nice to listen to. But I think the challenge would be, there's got to be a few words that it would get wrong and it would kind of throw
保持另一个运行，然后转向下一个渠道。这就是这本书的内容。酷。那么，实际上，我不知道，你肯定知道这一点，但亚马逊会自动拿走你的书吗？我想他们不能自动把它做成有声读物，但它有 Kindle 版、平装版和精装版吗？是所有这些格式吗？我希望它是音频版。因为我想要音频版，但他们说，Kevin，你需要录制它。我说，好吧，这有四五百页。我说，是的。有这个 Amazon Polly，听起来非常不错。但我认为挑战在于，肯定会有一些词它会弄错，如果你只是用 Amazon Polly 读整本书，它会让你
you off if you were to just Amazon Polly the whole book. Yeah. So basically with the Amazon, we have it in Kindle version, which is like whatever Kindle readers or any sort of e-reader, but then we also have like a book version. So it's like a soft cover book. We don't have it in hardcover yet, but that's basically how it works with Amazon. It's pretty nice if people want to do their own book. Amazon is pretty much print on demand. So Amazon just has our PDF and whenever someone orders,
感到困惑。是的。所以基本上在亚马逊上，我们有 Kindle 版本，也就是任何 Kindle 阅读器或任何电子阅读器，但我们也有书的版本。所以它是一本平装书。我们还没有精装版，但这就是它在亚马逊上的运作方式。如果人们想做自己的书，这很不错。亚马逊基本上是按需印刷。所以亚马逊只是有我们的 PDF，每当有人订购时，
they have a warehouse that prints it for us and it's all Amazon based. Oh, very cool. Very cool. Yeah, so check that out. What is a way for people to reach you? What is a good way for people to do that? Yeah, so you that out. I think, what is a way for people to reach you? Like, what is a good way for people to do that? Yeah, so you can always email me, kevinatvoymedia.com.
他们有一个仓库为我们打印，一切都是基于亚马逊的。哦，太酷了。太酷了。是的，去看看吧。人们有什么方式可以联系你？人们有什么好的方式可以做到这一点？是的，所以你可以随时给我发电子邮件，kevinatvoymedia.com。
And for anybody listening, if someone wants a copy of the book and you can't afford it, I can send you a free copy. So just shoot me an email and I can do that. Cool, great. So kevinatvoymedia, we'll put that in the show notes. And yeah, I think that's amazing.
对于任何听众，如果有人想要一本这本书，但你买不起，我可以给你寄一本免费的。所以给我发封邮件，我就可以做到。酷，太棒了。所以 kevinatvoymedia，我们会把它放在节目说明中。是的，我认为这太棒了。
Yeah, it's another great benefit for students out there and for people out there who are just getting started. So take advantage of that. I think I've told this story on the podcast before, but one of the most powerful things that I did in my life was, it was kind of serendipitous. I went on, I went on BitTorrent talking about, you know, we were younger and going on Torrent. And I just said, what are the most popular book Torrents? And, you know, some of them were kind of obvious. So there was the Bible, there was the Quran. I mean, they're very popular, but then after like on the entry, like three or four, it was, it was something like 150 dummies books Torrent. And, you know, I started reading through, you know, things that were outside of my wheelhouse.
是的，这对学生和刚起步的人来说是另一个巨大的好处。所以利用这一点。我想我以前在播客上讲过这个故事，但我一生中最强大的事情之一是，这有点机缘巧合。我上了 BitTorrent，谈论我们年轻时上 Torrent 的事。我只是说，最受欢迎的书籍 Torrent 是什么？你知道，其中一些是显而易见的。有《圣经》，有《古兰经》。我的意思是，它们非常受欢迎，但在第三或第四个条目之后，它是像 150 本傻瓜书的 Torrent。你知道，我开始阅读那些在我能力范围之外的东西。
So I started reading up on negotiation. I read up on economics and that really shaped a lot of my interests for my whole life actually. And so if this sounds even remotely like something that you would be interested in, or even if you need this to finish your app, or you're wondering how you can get more folks to your app, take Kevin up on this offer or go on Amazon and grab a copy of it. And it could be a really great opportunity for folks out there. Cool. Well, I think this is a good time to sort of put a bookmark in it. I really thank you, Kevin, for coming on the show. Absolutely fascinating. I think you really kind of opened up a new dimension for a lot of the listeners out there.
所以我开始阅读关于谈判的内容。我阅读了经济学，这实际上塑造了我一生中很多兴趣。所以，如果这听起来哪怕有一点点是你感兴趣的，或者即使你需要它来完成你的应用程序，或者你想知道如何为你的应用程序吸引更多人，接受 Kevin 的这个提议，或者去亚马逊买一本。这对大家来说可能是一个非常好的机会。酷。好吧，我认为现在是做个标记的好时机。我真的很感谢你，Kevin，来到节目中。绝对令人着迷。我认为你真的为很多听众打开了一个新的维度。
And I'm sure they're going to love it. I really love talking to you. And so thanks for coming on the show. It's been awesome. Oh, thanks so much for having me. I appreciate it. I love the conversation too. It was really good.
我相信他们会喜欢的。我真的很喜欢和你交谈。所以谢谢你来到节目中。这太棒了。哦，非常感谢邀请我。我很感激。我也很喜欢这次谈话。这真的很好。
Cool. All right. Thanks, everybody out there. music by eric barn dollar programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy distribute transmit the work to remix adapt the work but you must provide an attribution to patrick and i and share alike in kind There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
酷。好的。谢谢大家。音乐由 eric barn 提供。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下分发。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，以重新混合、改编作品，但你必须向 Patrick 和我提供署名，并以相同方式共享。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。